welcome ladies and gentlemen to our Iowa
caucus show we are here in De Mo Iowa it
is I think it's like what negative 15
out right now we've got the Iowa caucus
results trackers pulled up but we still
have I think it could be an hour before
we know exactly who wins and what's
going on but there's a lot of
interesting data that's coming out so
we're going to talk about this there is
a lot of news that we'll probably get
into as we are waiting but we have a lot
of awesome guests and uh in the news
today of course the Iowa caucus is
taking Center Stage Donald Trump is the
huge favorite expected to win but there
is a shocking new poll showing that
among first time caucus goers V
ramaswami actually is leading Nikki
Haley's in second and Trump is in third
I don't know how much that will matter
because the core base of Voters are not
first-time voters so this should get
pretty interesting we've got massive
escalation in the Red Sea which could
lead to uh serious conflict crisis and
War higher prices so we'll talk about
all that and a bunch of other stuff um
we'll talk about the airlines getting
woke and going broke but I think a big
Focus Fus of today is going to be on the
strategies of these political campaigns
who's going to win why they're engaging
the things they are and of course Donald
Trump versus V ramaswami is big in the
news right now so we'll get into all
that but before we do my friends this
whole production brought to you in Iowa
is powered by based records that's B
records they got a bunch of awesome
artists you may be familiar with five
times August that dude is amazing we've
had him on the show before follow them
on Twitter based records that's like
based like basting a turkey and uh I
really do appreciate it they helped put
this whole thing together I've been I've
been I was just telling everybody it was
insanely expensive to be able to pull
this off so we're going to do the show
tonight until uh we normally end around
10 and do the members only but the
members only is not going to be members
only tonight we're going to bring in
audience Q&A around 10 p.m. Eastern and
we're going to go for about 45 minutes
where we have a hard stop because we
have to fly back on our very expensive
private jet because that's what we do
that's the only way we're able to pull
it off but we do have a deadline to get
out of here so um it should be really
interesting and we're gonna have a lot
of awesome people so also go to
timcast.net click join us become a
member support the show because that's
another way you can help make all of
this possible this show is powered
thanks to people like you you also get
access to our members only uncensored
show content you've got the Discord
server where you can hang out with
like-minded individuals it's a lot of
fun we really do appreciate your support
so smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to start off
the show we got Benny Johnson and Alex
brtz take it away whoever wants to
what's up Benny Johnson and um you know
you can subscribe my only
fans I hope I hope it's worth the money
it was take the glasses
off that's
hot hey that's for subscribers only who
are you what do you do for those that
might not know uh news and politics and
culture on uh YouTube Facebook Instagram
twitch Rumble kick other platforms that
I'm X and so forth well all right we got
Alex Alex he's blowing up by the way I
mean this guy gains more followers than
anybody I know on a daily basis he's
crushing it but I'm Alex brtz I am a
semi-professional Twitter Troll and a
professional full-time de simp Crusher
online and uh you know I'm excited for a
big Trump victory tonight right on we've
got a couple other guests we've got a
bunch of people who may be jumping in
and out I don't know exactly who may be
showing up because there are a lot of
people who' have expressed interests but
um we are uh uh we have been under the
impression the whole time and I just
want to make sure this is clear VI
ramaswami should be joining us at some
point in the night to discuss strategy
what's happening and so we're excited
for that of course we had him uh uh on
the show on Wednesday we did a big town
hall with him but considering how hectic
the night may be we have no idea how it
may turn out especially considering the
roads are covered in ice and it's like
minus5 but the plan is to have them
around we also got the uh uh the crew
here of course Lukowski is hanging out
hey guys my name is lowski of
thepolitical show.com and because of
biomics I'm also selling on blank blank
for 7,000 a load there if you want to
find out what the blank says go to
thepolitical shorts.com we also have
Sheamus here who just came out and
crawled out of the tunnels in New York
City good to see you brother hold on a
second so
Luke were those Irish tunnels
though just deeply Irish yes so
unbelievable by the way Luke was eating
seed oil how dare
you and Tim can vouch for that well I
caught him cuz I saw Luke sitting on the
couch eating a cracker and I recognized
instantly it was a Belita cracker from
the came out his tunnel and I was eating
a a a beef stick and then and then when
Luke got with soy you you had a soy
there's no soy in there you had you had
what red five red two gross there was
red three in that made from C that's
right I I I I confess there were
preservatives and coloring and corn
syrup in my beef stick but Luke was
eating seed oil couldn't preserve Luke's
reputation what do you eat what about
your too St diet how about that talk
about extra oil poisonous FL
drinker can the tunnels used for answer
the question Sheamus what were you doing
in the tunnels we're moving on I
actually legit want to know this is I I
am I am I am fed up we're moving on
Sheamus did however drink two Sprites
and had a piece of chocolate cake as he
was sick
anyway my name is Sheamus Goin uh I'm a
cartoonist political pundit I have a
podcast on Rumble that's on Hiatus right
now called shamer I also have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we upload a
new animated cartoon every single week
and I'm a co-host on sh cast that that's
right I'm uh I'm eating cross and I have
been eating very healthy while we were
we were in town I drink a lot of I've
been drinking a lot of hot tea chamomile
that was nice caffeine low caffeine
you're classy gentlemen hard hard to eat
healthy in Iowa I've got a bit of a pla
in my headphones hopefully it's not too
distracting we went to the Big Steer do
people everyone from Deone know what
that is Luke said apparently like
everyone I found that place I did uh
Deep dive Research into it yo you come
to Iowa go to the Big Steer that place
is awesome best riby in town Seafood was
Top Notch super good delicious butter
this like have enough seed oils for you
Luke no seed oil no the dressing they
made in house Ian asked about they were
like nope it's legit it's cream it's
like garlic but now that we've talked
about a bunch of nonsense let's talk
about the news all right here's the
first thing I got pulled up for you this
is actually really funny the first thing
I want to mention we have the New York
Times Iowa caucus results queued up for
those that are here watching live you
can see it we have on the screen right
here but what do you notice what do you
what do you notice in their uh default
breakout of the uh I notice our Buddy
isn't there who wants to who wants to
say it yeah no VI on V is not included
in the New York Times default breakout
you have to then click view all
candidates to bring him up along with
Chris Christie he dropped ASA Hutchinson
and Ryan Binkley yeah Christy did drop
out but he's still on the ballot dead
ass I don't even know who Ryan Brinkley
is he was the first person to do the
full grassly this cycle he did all 999
counties and uh he really he did oh wow
is he still running uh no he's he
suspended his campaign but I think he
still has a few folks going to caucus
for him and really and Hutchinson's been
out for a while no he's still in he's
still in he's still in yeah wow yeah
he's uh that's kind of depressing but
you know more power to him I guess 1% oh
is he really Chris Christie dropped out
but I I do love that uh V is not
included in their default breakout of
the of the total reporting should be
interesting to see what ends up
happening because of that it was the
same with CNN and Fox News yeah
apparently what what fox so we did we
did uh right along with v today and he
showed me like a screenshot from his Fox
News hit this morning he's like what's
going on guys like what is this oh he
pointed at the screen and it just showed
it's a poll it was a poll of who are you
caucusing for and they did not include
his name but the weird thing on CNN is
when you clicked uh the link and went
there it the big article was VI's face I
don't understand what was going on I
think if you go to CNN right now and it
probably just show you VI I guess that's
it but I suppose the the big news and
the big questions we can start talking
about right now is Donald Trump versus
VI Swami this is like the big subject
for the longest time everybody's kind of
wondering how it is that V is running
against Donald Trump but there's no
fighting and so we actually got to the
point where I think it was Dave Rubin
who tweeted that vake he I don't want to
get him wrong but Dave said something
the fact that Trump is working with or
for I'm with I'm sorry V is working with
or for Trump or something like this yeah
that was a big narrative that was being
pushed by uh the disantis camp for for
quite a while and um you know I think V
was smart for for a long time for not
taking shots at at president Trump and
uh he kind of stayed above the fry in
that fight uh but president Trump
certainly doesn't enjoy when people use
his face or name for for you know
Financial purposes and uh those t-shirts
that V was pushing with the safe Trump
vote the vake message I think that was a
little um I think that upset a few
people including president Trump and
rightfully so uh president Trump has
never liked when people use his name he
even sued little MC Miller over the song
Donald Trump and so uh I think that was
a a rookie mistake made by V and it
happened at an inopportune time for the
guy yeah so this is the story I just
Google searched the image India West is
the source I don't know what they are
but this image is real and it's V with a
group of young men and they're wearing
shirts that say save Trump vote V look
man I like v he's a he's a good dude
he's a smart guy he's a hardworking guy
but this is this was a mistake this was
a big mistake I understand the the the
message like okay Trump's his life is at
risk if the Deep State really wants him
to not be president that they'll stop at
nothing I get that but like to to rely
on that as a campaign message is a
little lame like you got to be the best
candidate not like oh that other guy's a
problem so vote for me instead that just
doesn't fly it doesn't it doesn't
sustain my opinion show me why you're I
mean look V has a great thing going as
if the Deep state does really stop at
nothing and and go after Trump and let's
not even explain like the worst that
could happen we're going to be happy
that it's not just Nikki Haley waiting
in in in in the bleachers yep make is
around that was the argument that I
overheard as he's doing radio interviews
all day uh with uh Alex Jones Bonino he
was like the argument I couldn't hear
Alex Jones or Bonino but you could tell
they were like Trump's going after you
why would you run with this stupid shirt
and his argument was Alex Jones you just
did 20 minutes we just did 20 minutes
together on how they're going to
assassinate Trump oh jeez so then what
happens next and Bonino you just did a
whole interiew interview where you and
Tucker talk about assassination of trump
for 30 straight minutes yep so what do
you what do you think's going to happen
next game theory that out for me so I
think that's I I I don't think that's
smart I don't think that t-shirt's smart
but that's the I think the Strate the
thought process behind the t-shirt is
cringy sure but I thought Trump's
response could have been better I think
he could have been a lot smarter about
this situation his statement today um
made more sense but he could have
reached out to Vivic he could have uh
sent out a message saying hey I don't
need saving thank you uh without kind of
dividing a lot of people as of course
you know Don Jr was here just a couple
days ago and he talked about how we
don't have a bench and this kind of
infighting I don't think is is
productive and I think it could have
been handled totally different in my
opinion well it is politics and V is
running for president against against
Trump and he has stayed out of uh you
know kind of the Firing Lane uh the
entire cycle so far that's true and this
was really his first hi Hiccup and
mistake I think of the campaign and uh
you know president Trump is a fighter by
nature and he typically doesn't hold
back saying things that are on his mind
and that was probably the first thing
that came to his mind yesterday and so
he put it out and you know look I think
a lot of us do like v a lot of us do
think he has a future in the movement
and a future in the party I don't think
it's uh this year uh but I do think you
know he's a young guy and uh when we're
talking looking at our bench down the
future I think Ronda santis St stepped
on a landmine this cycle and has no
future after this I think a lot of
people saw his response and and I think
some people took offense to it because
they kind of saw it as punching down and
and they saw it as infighting and and
and to me that's how just some people
reacted to it but um you know again it's
a crazy situation and um a lot of people
want it handle handled differ I think
the only smart I think the only smart
move here quite frankly is for Trump to
release a save vake shirt that would
have been yeah that would have been a
that would have been funny that
hilarious good that is good and be like
I got you right save the from
himself well I I want to make a point
Piggy backing off of what you said Alex
um with DeSantis and the fact that he
stepped on a landmine here it's just
fascinating me because yeah this is the
first time I've ever felt that I liked a
politician and hated their campaign it's
a very strange phenomenon I mean I don't
even like the guy anymore you don't like
him anymore at all sorry but finish your
point yeah no well my point was
basically just that and I I I've said
this on the show before I think that if
Trump and DeSantis are both strong
that's great for the United States of
America I want both of those men to be
as successful as possible and then going
up against each other in the cycle and
Des santis deciding to run has turned
out to be a complete disaster for him in
his campaign and he ended up basically
jumping head first into the politician
wood shipper that is Donald Trump I
believe to borrow the the phrasing from
Ain McIntyre and so there's a lot that
DeSantis has done that I think is
fantastic I would like to see him have a
strong future in politics but
unfortunately I think his campaign has
been a disaster and I also say that as
someone who's had friends work for him
people who I like I think the people
making decisions for really not uh
trustworthy and I I think they're making
bad calls and this is the moment that I
would like to uh formally apologize to
Will Chamberlain and Jordan L and Jord
Chamberlain good they're friends of ours
they're good friends of mine a good guy
and I want to apologize cuz on on the
show last week I said that they were
living in Maryland while working for
Ronda santz and that was not true and so
will I'm really sorry about that I
didn't I didn't know I made a mistake I
read these articles I I I assumed you
were still in the area cuz you had been
on the show earlier but they were
actually living in Florida at the time
when they were working for so seriously
sorry about that guys I mean it and when
Will's the one of the people I'm
thinking of Will's the man like I I
really like that guy yeah I don't know
how you get rid of will who's actually a
smart guy competent guy and then keep
some of these other dumpster fires
around so uh yep and and and this is
what I said to will if they put him in
charge Des sandz would be pulling way
higher he could be he could have the
campaign that V is having granted V made
this I think this is a mistake V made
but I still think he's doing really well
but I got to tell you when I mentioned
to you earlier I don't even like Ron
anymore I gotta be
honest Laura lmer put out that video
where confronts him and you know it's it
is I don't know how you describe it but
it is shocking to be confronted by Laura
lommer if you're if you're some of these
people right but a a question that
someone asked and she also asked was why
are you in Iowa when your state is is in
a state of emergency and I was like whoa
I I didn't even realize I looked it up
sure enough there's flooding and a
disaster going on in Florida and not
only did he come out here but correct me
if I'm wrong I'm hearing that he brought
out his gator his Governor's gorial
staff as well yes and I was like whoa
whoa whoa dude dude this is this is not
okay okay he he would have earned way
more political points by saying I'm not
going to be able to to to campaign in
Iowa understand why there are people who
depend on me I will never abandon the
people who voted for me people of Iowa
blah blah blah instead he was like I'm
out he flies in flies out comes here and
then goes to campaign in a blizzard
where all the stores are shut down we
were walking around outside the and like
it wasn't even snowing very hard but the
snow had come overnight and the
restaurants are closed everything's
closed bar under snow for what reason
did he decide to come out here when
people are canceling events he he
actually abandoned his State during a
state of emergency flooding into
disaster to campaign in a state that was
dealing with its own weather I was just
that pissed me off I'm sorry man and
weather that people from Florida have no
idea how they have to deal with Florida
Florida people don't know how to deal
with ice and snow and cold and yeah I
what's the gator guy going to do up here
huh as a person yeah that's right lift
your legs when you walk so two things
one press down Joe Biden
that but can you lift your legs that
high in Boots like that is the question
it was fun I got I have big boots
they're like the big polar boots
Balenciaga baffins how big is the heel
it's pretty big oh oh they got they
wedges inside they give me about good
four inches you know can I pull the
audience real quick what do you guys
make of a man that will wears high heels
in a campaign
Trail and that's okay
it's okay yeah I got a I got a bit I got
a question for you guys we were talking
in the Green Room beforehand about um
basically the liberal economic order
most powerful force on Earth most
powerful Global government ever created
so if these guys Viv and Donald Trump
are saying like we're going to we're
going to disrupt it my thought is okay
well then your life is on the line so if
you do win the presidency you're going
to have to go into hiding or govern from
like some secret location and they were
like no that would be like an
abandonment I'm like but if you stay in
contact with the people via internet
video be like I have no choice but to be
in a Mountain Base what do do you guys
think that's a good idea you think it's
unnecessary what do you think going
against the liberal World Order well I
mean they're talking about dismantling
the FBI which is essentially going
against the liberal economic order well
so let's let's let's PR a little bit I
know there's a lot of people who are
probably uh more General viewers we've
covered this quite a bit but the liberal
economic order is a system you can uh
that was built after World War II Ian
brings up quite a bit it's a legitimate
thing this is not conspiracy theory I
know the media is going to try and claim
it is it's uh what is it the CFR the
Council on Foreign Relations they might
be it was started in 1949 and they were
like this is going to guarantee we don't
have World War III they built American
Le rules-based economy is what they call
it and they built all these American
military bases they use American money
and they've been enforcing it so they're
like these people are like we got to
create a new world order this liberal
economic ORD is no longer effective we
got to create a new system is where
they've been like the world economic
forum is starting to step in but this
liberal economic order is kind of now
being siphoned into this new world order
that they're trying to this global
banking thing um and has like was kind
of a bull like he kind of when he when
he canel the the the transpacific
partnership you could see that he was
not playing that game he was not going
to sell out the United States well
here's here's a question I want to ask
too because Ian's bringing up this point
if you're going up against the machine
they will do anything to stop you and as
you know you were just pointing out V
was mentioning that Alex Jones Dam ma
are talking about the potential
assassination Tucker Carlson Tu Caron
and and the joke everyone else has is
that Trump picked Nikki Haley as VP he'd
have to get a food taster cuz they're
going to want to get her in as possible
but let's be real too when V says save
Trump vote V it's like what makes you
think you're immune to the same things
if if V's really a threat to the system
like he's campaigning on you know why
would they why would the system let him
in and so like he has to he needs to
figure out that message before it lands
uh because that doesn't make a ton of
sense I just want I just want to add one
more point before we we move on for me
personally there's a lot of things that
are happening right now that we should
be talking about specifically World War
III that we are probably in right now
the Client List Americans are fatter
sicker and more depressed than ever but
we're talking about calendars and cringy
t-shirts the conversation should really
be about the establishment versus the
anti-establishment this is where the
conversation needs to be there's a lot
at stake here and and to me we're we're
arguing over superficial issues when
there's so much deeper things that we
could be exposing right now fighting for
and talking about that that sadly we're
not talking about which is kind of
disappointing for me personally I want
to cover some of these issues um I agree
Luke results are going to start coming
in but we do have some big issues
especially uh Taylor Hansen is reporting
on a really crazy is we'll get to later
in the show where you've actually got
police officers they're off duty but
using public equipment to facilitate
human smuggling operations on the border
crazy stuff coming out of this is tenant
media shout out to tenant media we have
the show the culture war with them
obviously full disclosure but uh
Taylor's got some excellent reporting we
we'll pull up later as Luke points out
there's a lot of issues but I want to
talk a little bit a little bit about the
caucus two big issues this is a new
report from cnr.com
shock poll majority of firsttime Iowa
caucus goers support VI ramaswami Trump
is in third place among this group with
29% surprisingly I I believe it's Nikki
Haley what who has second place right
well hers her numbers come from first
time GOP caucus goers and it's because
she has a lot of Democrats caucusing
exactly and so these are people that are
not actually going to be voting for
Republican in in in the in November this
is the this is a crazy thing I saw I
think Mark Cuban tweeted this calling
for crossover voters Democrats to come
in and vote for Nikki Haley basically
sabotaging the Republican primary
process why does the why does the part
why does the state party of Iowa allow
that like why does the Republican state
party of Iowa allow that that makes
absolutely no sense here's a question
how long have you been in
Iowa L than a week You' met some people
You' gotten out you went to restaurants
y yeah have you met a Nikki Haley
supporter no no never not that I of yeah
yeah it's it's like meeting a doo bird
or or a Joe Biden voters try yeah like
try and capture you know try and capture
one for science science what are you
I've never I've never I don't know one
seen one we've met Joe Biden voters
we've never I've never met a Joe Biden
supporter okay yeah they voted against
Trump essentially yeah and and even like
the leftists who are like I voted for
Biden it's like yeah I don't like the
guy at all I just think Trump's a
fascist or blah blah blah but I saw I
when I saw this uh thing from Mark Cuban
where he's like crossover voters you're
saying why does I allow it it's really
simple man Democrats probably a long
time ago switched their party with the
intention of sabotaging the primary we
we talked about it even in 2020 this is
a strategy of having your people go to
open primaries to choose whoever you
think is going to lose or just to cause
chaos and damage well if it makes any of
the folks in attendance are watching
feel better Liz Cheney tried to do this
in Wyoming and she lost by 40 points she
tried to get all the Democrats in
Wyoming to register and vote for her um
I don't think it's smart that some
states do it but that's just the fact of
the matter um it's but it's not about
any state doing it even if you have a
closed primary caucus process a Democrat
one year ago re switches party
affiliation to Republican waiting for
the moment they can come and do this
there's nothing there's no way to stop
it it just means that Democrats are
there are a large percentage of democrat
voters who are lying to sabotage the
Republican primary I would like to thank
your program and and and what you guys
do for sending your reporters to the
Nikki Haley events and she has totally
close the doors to most conservative
media she won't allow cameras inside of
her stump speeches she's terrified that
her speeches will get out there and so
your videos of like talking to the
attendees and saying yeah I'll vote they
say I'll vote for Biden before I vote
for Trump like those are the First
videos that were actually coming out of
the Nikki Haley events this entire
campaign cycle so you guys did a great
job on that well that's uh shout out to
cnr.com elad eliahu doing this ground
reporting a lot does a great job he he
doesn't go in he's not yelling at people
he just ask him a basic question who are
you supporting Niki if it's not niik who
will you vote for and they say Biden and
their voters saying Ukraine's the number
one issue uh you know these people are
are not going to be Trump voters and
that's okay we don't need them but uh
the V has been interesting he's uh
attracting a new demographic I think to
the party and I think a lot of when he
eventually drops out I think most of his
if not all of his supporters will come
and vote for president Trump yep um but
you know he's a young energetic guy uh
and he attracts a similar type of person
that President Trump does uh but V's
team has really made an effort to go
after the the young vote like the 18 20
year olds and uh you know the Andrew
take crowd it's it's brilliant
uh going for the younger voter I think
V's whole play is for the future I do
think the save Trump vote thing was was
a huge misstep but I think right now and
I say this too because right now with
the V versus Trump thing there's people
are getting attacked online by like
crazy you've got these DieHard Trump
supporters saying they're all grifters
yeah okay look I'm gonna throw some
criticism at Ian miles Chong because he
posted that really deceptive image that
was like mainstream media esque where
it's a very tight shot from the third
row of a trump rally and then behind V
his whole room when apparently Trump's
Trum Trump had like 2500 people plus
overflow and a had 500 capacity like
let's not play those games we don't need
to do that but there are a lot of people
that I think are are going hard after
anybody who is talking to the or or
interviewing him claiming that this a
paid coordinated thing totally not true
possible I don't know maybe some people
are getting paid by V's campaign we
didn't get anything uh from V except I
will say full disclosure the building we
are in l tweeted that we are in his
campaign office technically correct not
literally correct his campaign office is
down the hall around the corner I think
that's fair to point out we are in an
unused portion of the building we
actually had to talk with the owner
about the use of the space and and what
it meant and I'm I'm just going to tell
everybody El we actually we were like at
odds with the V campaign because they're
super noisy and we're trying to do a
show but I'm like I don't want to
disrupt someone else's campaign yeah and
they've given us full access to that
office which is where I got my tea as in
VI campign they're being really nice
shout out to V te being bought off by
tea that's right that's right but I want
to make sure being transparent and clear
with that but I but I also want to point
out that when Laura Point mentioned
about being loyal to Trump I don't think
she articulated that very well I don't
like loyalty in politics what do you
guys think no no hold on I want to
address this this is the point why I'm
bringing it up there is an issue of
being honorable and loyal to Donald
Trump and I agree with it now let all
the disantis people scream Maga cult BS
whatever no I'll tell you what it means
it means I didn't vote for Donald Trump
in 2016 and then I saw a president who
started no new Wars I saw him set
deadlines for ending Foreign Wars which
the Democrats told me were all bad
during Obama but it but made worse he
brings Abraham Accords he negotiates
with North Korea all of these great
foreign policy moves some bad ones don't
get me wrong but an overall net positive
and the whole time they're destroying
his life they're targeting his children
his net worth is dropping now they're
trying to take from him his properties
in New York City with a with a with a
fraudulent trial he's being criminally
prosecuted across the board I'm sorry
man when it comes to the issue of
loyalty I can ignore policy and say I'm
not going to abandon a guy and vote for
V after this guy jumped in the trenches
and caused himself personal damage to do
good things for me and the United States
that's loyalty but that being said
between V and Trump I understand V's
point about they're going to try and
stop him agreed however Donald Trump has
experience in his first term I believe
that if if V were to win right now he
would not be as effective as Trump in
certain areas because he will step on
the landmines that they laid out for
Trump in the first term that Trump now
knows about so I I still think there's a
logical path forward for why Donald
Trump is the right person to pick and I
also think there's a question of Honor
and loyalty to a guy who's sacrificing a
lot well so honor don't turn away from
who you believe in because of fear I
agree with that but I believe that we
should be loyal to the process and it
sounds like you're loyal to Trump's
process which I understand but if what
does that mean you're loyal to his
actions what he's done is like I want
more of that I I respect humans that do
that thing but no that's that's not
correct you're saying all the things he
did it's not about like I love the guy
no matter what he does I'll vote for him
I'm
saying he I'm saying you can ignore the
good things he's done that's that's
that's my point if if we take all of his
policies and everything he did for this
country and just put a blanket over it
and say the only wish issue we are
addressing is this man ran to be
president ignited a base and they have
been stabbing him in the back
relentlessly that guy made sacrifices
for me I won't abandon him no I don't
like that I I think I hear where you're
coming from though but and and I think
for the voters I don't think voters
necessarily have to be loyal to a person
right I think president Trump has earned
a lot of respect and a lot of
appreciation from the voters and that's
why they're going to vote for him
tonight and across the country but when
when Laura lummer I think when she's
talking about the Loyalty I think she's
talking about people like aanda santis
who was a backbench congress member
until he got in his hands and knees and
cried in front of trump begging him for
his endorsement basically getting the
coronation to become governor of Florida
president Trump worked with him made
sure he got in he got rally after rally
after rally Des santis was running TV
ads you know basically saying you know
I'm president Trump's number one guy and
you know build the wall reading Trump
books to his kids and he he embraced a
trump brand to become who he is today
and then he totally ditched Trump uh
when it became politically convenient
for him and then when you look at some
of these other influencers that Laura
lommer in the trenches fighting online
Simply Built their audiences like I look
at Tim different than I look at some of
these other folks look at Jenna Ellis
because Jenna Ellis built her audience
off of the back of trump supporters and
president Trump Tim built his audience
on his own doing his own thing and so
who he wants to support he can support
who he wants but when you're Jenna Ellis
or you're a John cardillo or you're a
bill Mitchell and your content is only I
love Trump for five six years and just
in the reply section defending him and
all of a sudden you switch well like
that's where people
like Loy and their followers left them
in dros Bill Mitchell lost 90,000
followers over the last you know year
because he became the biggest to Santa
shill John cildo similar situation and
so like but that like loyalty matters to
that to that extent but uh I don't think
the voters necessarily have to be loyal
but I think president Trump certainly
makes a great case I look at I'm loyal
yeah John c i it took me a second and
then it processed I'm loyal to the US
Constitution and the process of the
American function and if someone better
comes along than the person I've been
supporting for 20 years I'll vote for
the new better person and if that person
that I've been supporting goes crazy
they should step down and get out of the
way so the next guy can come and that's
how our systems build agreed don't I
don't see that playing a role right now
yeah but I think the other question too
is if somebody has been good for 20
years how do you know that the person
who's coming up isn't just good in
rhetoric and they're actually going to
be decent when they take office because
that's one of the values that's one of
the benefits of having a political
leader who has some experience is you're
able to say okay I know what their track
record is whereas this other guy could
have great rhetoric but I don't know
what he's going to do I is in like
military and monarchy I don't think it
has a place in republics we got some
numers com so uh less than 1% of the
votes have come in already it is 7:30
Donald Trump is at 67.5% with 243 votes
Des sand is in second Nikki Haley is in
third VI Rami in fourth is that good for
Trump so far this is good for Trump not
good at math who's the guy that voted
for Chris Christie there's one vote for
Chris Christie Ryan Bley got a vote his
wife voted for Ryan B split voted for
Ryan I'm real sorry ASA Hutchinson still
running you said he's still running and
he got zero and chrisy got one he's
still in the
race I'm sorry okay so hey look if I if
I were caucusing tonight and I'm from
Iowa and I've caucused before as an
Iowan I no longer live in Iowa I live in
Florida I would not be caucusing for
Ronda sand I'd be caucusing for Donald
Trump I fully expect to vote for Donald
Trump in 2024 in a general election my
issue with the whole my issue with the
whole what Alex is talking about but
then also this whole like loyalty
argument is I think at the root of it is
we injected money into the influencer
world and were able to flip influence
ERS in a very cringy way talk a little
bit about cringe political campaigns
here and uh I'm not going to name anyone
but it's fully available for everyone to
see online who's getting paid it's also
fully available in FEC reports you can
go check who's on the payroll of which
campaigns right bigname influencers you
can go find them all the reports are
public and I don't like that you getting
paid Luke I I wish there were some
people that shock Dan santis is paying
people that that shocked me I couldn't
believe do we publicly see who who he's
paying Riley Gaines is a good example I
didn't know that really the Sant
campaign is paying Riley gains wow for
for Consulting just two weeks before or
two weeks after she endorsed him so you
know the timing was interesting but I
find that practice two weeks after she
endorsed him she gets paid by his
campaign $10,000 interesting so I find
that practice gross you know and and I
like I that was something that I wanted
because I went and spent I went and
spent the day doing a documentary for
our my tenant media show called in the
arena where we go and we show this
process shout out tenant
and I was accused of being disloyal
because I was going out with the vake
but I just want to tell an interesting
story and he's the only guy that had
campaign uh events today right and they
were all over the state and it was very
interesting how how how else can we look
bunch of gen z a bunch of gen Z kids by
the way that he paying well no that were
showing up to this and saying that they
found him through Tik Tok and I'm not on
no oh so VES events were stacked by and
large with Tik Tok kids he's clever
which very uh some more results have
just come in a little bit uh V's still
in fourth and uh but he's within 15
votes of Nikki Haley I gotta be honest
I'd be really happy if Donald Trump wins
resoundingly and V's in second place
Trump's number so far I just want to say
nice I just don't like the paid
influencer model pay you for your
endorsement model call that corruption
that used to be called like plain and
simple like corrupt like you do that in
politics you pay someone for an
endorsement you call that corruption do
you know any other people that he's
paying that are prominent influencers or
do you not want to well there are War
there are ways there there are ways that
these campaigns are shield in the name
winner is in with less than 1% of votes
the New York Times has called Donald
Donald Trump the winner of the iauc I
was told I was told by team DeSantis
that Dan santis was going to win that
didn't happen wow wow less than 1% votes
in no way are there other 7:32 I don't
understand still very is my mic even on
yeah I think you're a little quiet and
so was Sheamus yeah well that's that's
good for both of them actually perfect
maybe you're in that screaming MCH oh
Ryan binkley's got two votes Bley please
I just want V to beat Nikki he's he's
within 12 votes of beating Nikki Haley
that's incredible that's a good sign you
got this I got to be honest I I just
hope fails the race has been called by
the Associated Press the race was called
before most of the votes were reported
which often means the call was based on
polls and other data oh okay so so we
can go home now is done I no I think
it's I I I think we're all happy to hear
that uh don Donald Trump won of course
he was going to win he's at 70% his
number is only increasing but the the
race that matters is the cultural race
and that is I would like to see V Crush
D santis and Nikki haly CBS CBS News Now
calling New York CBS News
CNN Trump campaign officially shares the
AP message that he won I I personally
find Viv to be the superior candidate
but I know that politics is a popularity
contest I can accept that and Donald
Trump is massively popular what do you
think particularly you and anybody that
wants to talk about it as a VI Donald
Trump ticket regardless of who's I mean
I think Donald Trump is the the lead I
think VI has certainly positioned
himself for an incredible future is it
in 2024 on the ticket I don't know um
but I think we have a lot of great
options I'm a big fan of Dr Ben Carson I
think he's been a tremendous uh asset to
to our movement and he's a really great
man um I think V certainly is should be
considered um but I do believe that
President Trump uh has made up his mind
and we'll probably uh find out who is it
we'll probably find out that uh sooner
than later and this primary should wrap
up sooner than later because you know
Joe Biden just posted his financials
that he raised this last quarter 117
million he gets to save all of his money
and prepare for the general election
this primary so far $250 million has
been spent and look at that margin right
now and so we are just blowing money
that we need in November and so we need
some of these Jokers to drop out and so
we can take the fight to Joe bid man
you're you're so right this was a
spectacular waste of money it's going to
be this if it's they're going to call it
in like 29 seconds and how much money
was 300 votes coming in well how much
money was spend here Chris Christie was
talking about it on the um leaked audio
right like when he was he didn't know
he's Live Well he was he was tallying
$200 million s has spent $999 million in
the state of AA 99 million and he's got
75 votes far5 votes yeah do you work for
Trump's campaign I do not work for
Trump's campaign but I uh am close with
most of the folks over there uh been
blessed to become uh friends with the
president I'm excited to see him in in a
few minutes here uh he's going to be in
great spirits and in great
mood ran Bley has two votes now I just
want to mention dou his count I do need
to point out the uh uh while you may be
upset that Ron spent all of that money
uh when Bloomberg was running and
everyone in the country was laughing and
spent half a billion dollars doing it
just understand he spent a lot of that
money on YouTube channels that hated him
and so congratulations funding the
people who spread the message that you
suck yeah so understand when these
people are spending money it's great for
the for the uh cultural ecosystem what
they're trying to do is that campaigns
like Des santis I don't know if he's
buying ads in social media the way
Bloomberg was doing but they're trying
to counter the message of people who are
saying Bloomberg sucks it doesn't work
so all he ends up doing is giving money
to people who hate him to make more
shows about why he's bad so it doesn't
really work the way they want
congratulations on wasting that money is
it is the disantis what's he spending
the 99 million on is it TV commercials I
bet it's a lot of TV so he had he for
months he was saying we're gonna win you
know please find this clip you got to
show your audience this clip they say
Ron how do you pronounce your last name
is it D santis or D santis and he goes
It's pronounced winner you got to find
this clip you got to find this clip got
him can I ask
it's pronounced winner as as someone
who's been watching online and chuckling
to myself what was it that do you live
in Florida I do so what was it that like
sent you over the edge with the team Des
santis I think how
uh cuz nobody goes harder than you well
they certainly were a lot of fun to spar
with early on just because you know I'm
as a professional Twitter troll I try to
get under people's skin and the second
you like one once somebody shows that
the their skin is like has been breached
you just keep pressing in and you press
in and so it just becomes a lot of fun
and so uh they reacted to everything we
tried to bait them into fights that
weren't important and then they spend
days and days on a news cycle that uh
was completely irrelevant to the
campaign and they couldn't help
themselves they engaged every single
time they fought on every single issue
you know I think Tim pointed out a
really important one he said you know
the AI fight so they get caught making a
video with Dr fouchy and Donald Trump
hugging in Ai and incredibly shady and
Tim P called him out Senator JD Vance
called him out Josh Holly called it out
they said and then their response is
well Donald Trump shared this meme of
Ronda santis riding a roseros it's
basically the same thing and like they
would they die on their Hills they
refuse to say I was wrong and they they
just push in and push in and uh whoa we
got good news f is within nine votes of
Nikki Haley come on get it get it I hope
Ryan Binkley beats Nikki
Haley Alex in your experience trolling
have you gained troll resistance are you
able to resist you well I grew up in
video game culture you know so you log
on you play Call of Duty you play you
know whatever game you play and you sit
in your with your buddies and you say
the meanest things you can say to each
other for you know all day every day and
then you get off and you you know see
each other at school the next day and
you're best friends right like I don't
words don't hurt me so like I don't
really care if somebody's like uh you
know they call me AB 35k or they say I
have no upper lip or whatever it may be
like like I appreciate the attacks and I
find humor in the attacks and so I like
the game but you get these guys take it
so personally and they're so offended by
it and they react emotionally instead of
logically and we just play with them my
conspiracy theory is that the people
running to San's campaign are Trump
supporters and they got together and
said what can we do to sabotage Ronda
santis because if you look at what
they're doing it literally makes no
sense no sense I I don't want to call
out high-profile individuals who don't
want to get involved in fights they
don't need to be involved in but we've
had guest on the show who are prominent
conservative Personalities in in
different range of array of spaces what
I mean by that is like being as vague as
possible is like an Entertainer perhaps
and they say things like when they show
up to the studio they'll be like hey I'm
getting attacked by these disantis
people what's going on and I'm just like
what did you say I don't know and I'm
just like well there you go welcome to R
campaign attack everybody and insult
them and be condescending and mean and
apparently that's what they think's
going to get him the votes it's oh with
two votes from Nikki Haley oh V you got
to Crush N come on come on oh they it's
nimrata that's right we're supposed to
use our real name that's right Nikki
Haley says we must use our real names
online oh yeah so this is online and you
must call her by her real name Nikki
Haley no Nikki haly just jumped 17 and G
none got six what percent are we at now
or is it give you a real time update 1%
of votes oh it's still 1% I just dm' you
the video on Twitter oh okay I sent you
the article about it too on Twitter
Nikki Haley changed her hband did you
know this yes she changed her husband's
name to Michael Yes Nikki Haley uh it
was Bill or something yeah it was like
Bill and she's like I'm gonna call you
Mike she's like I'm G to call you Mike
she said I'm going to call you Big Mike
so there's been rumors for years there's
been rumors for years of alleged Affairs
Nick like there's a staffer that came
forward and said they had an affair with
Nikki and I don't think it was an affair
if this guy allowed his wife to change
his name I don't think it's an affair I
think he might be well whatever it is I
mean like there's levels of this there's
like there's levels of being insulted
there's like first like your wife
hyphenating instead of taking your name
and then there's like you taking her
name and then there's like her changing
your first name and that's where they
are as a couple your up here like I dump
the Michael it is it is getting brutal
Nikki Haley is now well above VI so
early I suspect Nikki Haley pulls ahead
of Ron really uh and Ron finishes in
third place with about 15% you think the
will be in fourth look I think think V
uh is going to be very close to Ron he
campaigned so hard look look money still
matters and you know V uh has probably
been the most uh Frugal of the first of
the top four candidates and uh he's
putting up an interesting fight but Ron
wasted almost a hundred million and it's
probably going to be very close to aake
in the race so I you should I play this
you have to play this video all right
here we go I got a long last name
European name steinhauser there's been
some confusion over your last name in
the pronunciation and I'm just wondering
to correct the record what is it no it's
ridiculous these stupid things listen
the way to pronounce my last name
winner a long last I'm sorry man I don't
know who hold I'm Chang picking on a guy
that has
autism stop it please leave him alone Bu
you're you're a pro at this is that clip
going viral tonight oh yo yo guys guys
guys Nikki Haley is a within 16 votes of
beating Ronda
santis wow she's going to Ron's going to
finish in in in a third place and look
if he was a smart guy he drops out
tomorrow morning endorses president
Trump tucks his tail between his legs
goes back to Tallahasse but I don't
think that's you're right man I mean
here's a question so Ron's gone hard in
the pain against Trump right like I
haven't missed this on the campaign
Trail I can't pay attention to
everything everyone says but Ron's gone
real hard he's ran directly at Trump how
do you take that back right how do you
then endorse the guy I think it's
expected in politics I mean Maybe not
maybe not because trashing your opponent
is different than explaining why you're
the best and also we've seen people get
Trashed by Trump and then endorse him
it's not exactly the same but people
have very clearly humiliated themselves
lying Ted Cruz yeah he he knocked Ted
Cruz's wife too like he he hold on hold
on I think he just he called Ted Cruz
lying Ted and then after the fight was
over it changed to lion like and then it
was like it was honor to be clear Ted
Cruz did not endorse president Trump for
this cycle so Ted still has n Haley is
within two votes of beating Ronda I
think the best thing Ron can do is
support the party and not support
necessarily I mean he could go support
Trump but I mean you got to you got a
party Unity at some point and um maybe
they'll make amends you know I don't
think they they dislike each other
personally is it still 1% of the vote in
one% of votes are in I mean hey it's
early it's S I think we're going to
start getting big chunks and it's going
to jump up faster and faster as the
night we're getting closer to 8 o'clock
uh I do think it's funny they already
called it for Trump though weird like
instantly they called it yeah with less
than 1% of and they're like ah he won
you know what's funny is because they're
saying that it's been called by the AP
before most were in which means it was
based on polls it's probably just some D
to the AP being like guys there's no way
anyone else is winning just say Trump
won like I want to go home let's just
get out of here these caucus things
people just go and then they vote but
like anyone can go and vote be
registered so you can register are they
paying people to go do it like is the
santis 99 million partly like we're
going to make sure that you have got a
car to the caucus that you can get there
early they imported the entire cabinet
and government agency staffers of the
State of Florida to go door too in you
know this frigid temperature uh and beg
people to go caucus for run and uh you
know it obviously didn't work out too
well for them a lot of out ofers showing
up at somebody's door in Iowa like the
Iowans you know don't really appreciate
that a whole lot um but this is that the
evacuation plan I've SP a lot of time
with VI I've talked to him many time
multiple times four or five times and uh
I've been insulated in his campaign in
the last week I thought there was a shot
that maybe he would come up on top this
to me is like I'm done with this
Republican political debacle Trump's got
it this is it Trump got it Trump's the
nominee it that that that I look Trump
has gone from 70 at less than 1% with
the race called for him he's now at
57.7% even if Ron Nikki and vies were
all added up they're still not beating
Donald Trump he's too famous he's so
famous what about Ry we I'm actually
curious has he gotten is no there's zero
chrisy sorry not Chris Christie has four
what if like Chris Christie flies at
those four people like has dinner with
him he's like thank you so much for
thinking of
me I a nice thing the right thing we had
a request in because we call him Cris
Krispy uh on my show and we had a
request in to go to a Crispy Cream
that's right down the uh street from my
studio and to eat Nikki Haley's beating
Ronda s how
sad bird brain will be much easier to
destroy than Ron by the way we haven't
even started on well look Nikki
Democrats the the the rumor is and I
would warn everyone don't fall for this
trap should it be like Rhino Republicans
or you know whatever establishment
shills but the argument right now is
that Democrats are crossing party lines
to vote for Nikki if it goes to a
general election they're not going to
vote for Nikki no so she she might get
higher percentages in the primary
process she's not going to get in the
general that sounds like really really
dirty yeah that you could you go and you
you register as a Republican you youve
caucus for the wrong person and then you
can switch back to Democrat afterwards
come on that's insane yeah that's so
stupid Chen's political career right
that can't be allowed going forward I
mean you you register you register what
can you do about it I don't know a year
so it's 2023 you're like I don't want
Trump to win register as a republican a
year later you go in caucus for someone
else and then you in the general can
vote forever you want or you switch
parties after the caucus is over and
that's because a Republican vote for a
democrat in the no because you can
register for whatever party you want you
can change party affiliation you're free
to do so it's free speech or it's free
association or whatever Tim do you think
that all of the Twitter Bots for Ron
were able to vote in the Iowa caucus no
yeah I do think I I think Ronda his
campaign I don't I I don't I will say
this I don't know for sure I'm not
accusing him of doing anything but I
will say it does it does seem most
people would agree that a lot of the pro
descendant accounts online are Bots yeah
I don't know if they're say with the
campaign or not but you see they have
some generic name with a gator in the
name they'll have some kind of cartoon
character as the profile picture and
they all respond in the exact same ways
and I'm just like it is not organic at
least the Trump people say weird things
or insult you in different ways like who
no I'm just talking like like Maga guy
519 or whatever will
write yeah you're right I guess I do
that the tenis campaign walked right
into so much of this I mean that's wild
it was it was just like I I I'm you know
maybe it's a little crass or whatever
but that photo was posted of danes's
people and Christina Pasha had her knees
made red in you know Photoshop or
whatever I didn't get that what did that
mean after that it was like that was the
moment where I noticed she went from
dming with people I knew we were talking
with her about having her or attendance
come on the show after that photo came
out it was like just the Gates of Hell
had been Unleashed and I think that
broke her yeah I think it broke it
appeared to me that she was using camp
campign resources to settle personal
scores and she had a lot of the campaign
assets and and folks just went to battle
for her instead of actually doing
something that was helpful to the
candidate y this is crazy that n pulling
ahead yeah that's what it looks like
unfortunately wow she's she's up 23
Point votes so far on on Des santis so
if Ron drops a 10% that' be $10 million
per percentage Point that's not good wow
wow that's so much money uh who spent
more Nikki or Ron in Iowa Ron Ron put
his all of the eggs in in Iowa he had
his entire ground game here he bragged
about how great their operation was here
um never backed down his Super PAC had
their bus here basically the entire
campaign they pulled out a New Hampshire
uh many months ago and his whole
campaign was reliant on Iowa and that's
why he sought the endorsements of Steve
de and Bob Vander plats and these people
who were once considered Iowan King
maker King makers and I don't think any
campaign is going to be seeking their
endorsements uh next go around yo it's
it's it's kind of wild to have been
someone look year and almost two years
ago I'm hanging out with the daily wire
crew a story I've told a million times
and we're talking about why we think
Ronda santis is the guy it's well before
Trump was back in the race a lot of
things changed since then and we're like
Ron's young he's got energy he's got
great policy he's really working for
Florida everyone's really excited by him
and then as time went on we got a little
more disenfranchised it got to the point
where I was like yeah I'm kind of 50/50
I think Trump's back his speech was
pretty good I like Ronda Sanz we'll see
what happens I just got a text from
Wesley Hunt's uh Chief of Staff a Ronda
santis supporter just charged Wesley
while he
was a trump serate at caucus location
video coming soon whoa so these folks
aren't handling the loss well well this
is what I I hope W is okay they never
back down that's right oh my God here's
what I want to say about like there was
a period where Ronda FIS thank you thank
you I'm a father of three my dad jokes I
really appreciate any fathers in the
audience I really appreciate the
appreciation of the dad joke thank you
Ron was winning in the prediction
markets handily like two to one against
Trump over time Ron started doing that's
true yeah he start he started he started
doing worse and worse so someone like me
I start making apt points about how his
campaign is being run his launch was bad
he lacked Charisma and even after all
that I I like the guy's got good policiy
he's got to turn this around and what
did they respond with attacking anyone
who would dare criticize his failing
camp campaign now we're at the point
where we're like this guy has totally
failed but there are a lot of
personalities who attached them you know
tied their their hitch to the the the
danis wagon and no matter how bad things
got they kept saying no he's the best no
I refuse to back down a very bad dad Bob
bad what what are they going to do well
are they going to try and come back and
be like Maga please take me back into
your warm bosom I'm sorry I supported
this guy who whose campaign was
miserable yeah or or they do a Lincoln
project type group and uh you know I
don't really want some of those folks on
our side we've they've actually become a
detriment of Ron I don't want I mean I
don't really want a lot of his people
being advocates for us out there like
normal normal people look at some of
these people like they think they're
weird so uh I hope they stay far away
from Trump World uh moving forward I
would love to make it less about who and
more about what we do moving forward as
a union like this making the America
great again like we do it constantly
we've made this country great uh let's
do it again let's let's let's
reinvigorate the country with new
technology and give the 21st century a
run for its money I to be honest I don't
even care who the president is if
they're willing to do that well I think
I think this is a a great message and I
think some of these numbers are going to
hold pretty pretty closely here and
president Trump I believe we'll get over
50% and that is a mandate the voters
want president Trump he's going to go on
to win New Hampshire go on to win South
Carolina this primary should end we
should we should come together uh and
and focus our fight on Joe Biden this
this is interesting uh Johnson County
Nikki Haley has the lead if I may I'm
from Johnson County this this is where
the University of Iowa is this is the
large one of the the largest centralized
liberal populations in Iowa and this is
what the polling showed that Joe Biden
voters support Nikki Haley and these are
Democrats voting in the Republican this
is liberal land right there this is the
college town like communist Marxist
professors Johnson County that's Story
County that is Nikki Haley is winning in
Story County also a college County and V
is in second that's Ames that's the
University of uh that's Iowa State why
do you think it is that the Democrats
generally are supporting Nikki Haley
same policy as J it's Hillary Clinton
yeah right a warh 2.0 it's but she's not
even like Joe Biden with a wig on but
it's not even a joke to be like haha
she's like Hillary it's like no she's
literally got the same policies it's
crazy Jo Biden wears simar you know
Nikki Haley gets offended if you call
illegal aliens criminals yeah you know
she says climate change is a national
security threat Nikki Haley is straight
up on video multiple times saying that
Hillary Clinton's her hero right and she
worked with Trump she was his ambassador
to the UN that's what it was what she
was appointed by Trump yeah and then she
raised her hand one time and then was
she okay was she cool then was she the
same it's kind of a role I
think we should defund the UN I think we
should be out of the UN so you just put
somebody there that wants the title but
they don't really do a whole lot it's
part of that liberal economic order
World Police thing I think look I think
president Trump has been pretty uh open
to the idea of getting out of the un uh
and and pulling out of n like it's it
benefits us zero so you know I want to
to jump to a story we'll keep the the
results tracking but this is big news
and as we're talking about Nikki Haley I
think it's important to bring up this
video now I'm not 100% sure this is the
correct video not an accurate video
that's from 2021 that's not an accurate
video okay good thank you for pointing
that out yep we have this report from
ABC News houthi fired missile strikes a
uh a missile strikes a us-owned vessel
off Yemen in the Gulf of Aiden raising
tensions so we're now hearing not only
is the US and the UK bombing this uh the
houie rebels they're firing on US own
ships they fired on us warships war is
escalating in a very very dangerous
fashion even if it doesn't get crazier
from this point and this is the level
it's at trade is going to be heavily
affected your the cost of your goods is
going to go up Nikki Haley is the
candidate of more war fore an
intervention and lying about it the
whole way through Yep this is why as I
know we're supposed to be this honorable
news program program checking the
results no Nikki Hal is awful don't vote
for her I hope she loses otherwise World
War I so uh uh Miller the Trump campaign
ruled out today uh v as VP but did not
rule out Nikki when asked but break this
down for me what do you mean he I saw
the clip he was asked could Dicky Haley
presumably be the VP and he's like that
that's in the cards or something to that
effect he didn't rule it out why
ultimately well there could be two oh
gosh Laura Trump or Kimberly guilfoil
they also if you if you look at the
political if you look at all the
establishment political analysts they're
going to Trump and they're telling them
make sense for Trump not to say yes or
no also makes sense for him because he
could essentially stop Nikki from
attacking him during the selection cycle
by possibly maybe giving her a
possibility and therefore she's she's
going to have to be careful with the
criticism that she launches against him
so strategically when you look at the
situation anything and everything is
plausible here but I think as
Independent Media we need to send out
the message that Nikki Haley is horrible
she is awful we talked to to Tucker
Carlson specifically about this and I
asked them would you support uh Trump
Nikki ticket and Tucker Carlson said
absolutely not I think I think I think
we need that message out there more than
ever said more than that he said I'd
beat the protest against that I I can
say this Trump has always promised that
he will fight who's ever in second place
and for the longest time Ronda santis
was in second place and so Nikki Haley
didn't face the ire but if you're
starting to pay attention now Trump's up
you know his super packs done a couple
million dollars in attack ads against
Nikki Haley in New Hampshire uh and
there 's a ton of material Nikki Haley's
been public office for over 20 years
she's 20 years of baggage you get to go
through 20 years of stupid statements
and and terrible policies that she
supported and uh she's about to feel the
heat because she's in second now and uh
she's not going to enjoy being in second
who knows if she's there for long uh
maybe V is the the the last man standing
ultimately after you know besides Trump
has Trump attacked Nikki oh yeah he
calls her bird brain uh he thinks that
she's a stupid person so he calls her
bird brain he's not wrong um you know uh
there there's great ads up right now
showcasing Nikki you know being uh being
more concerned about protecting the
feelings of illegal aliens than
protecting our borders um she she really
doesn't want you to call illegal aliens
criminals and so she's incredibly weak
and you're going to see a lot more of
that I'd assume now that she's firmly in
second place I think Trump is the
incumbent it's like a second term
president so like at this point I hope
that he focuses on what and telling us
what he wants to do next like it is very
important rally go go to agenda 47 go to
Trump donaldjtrump.com and go to agenda
47 every policy position for his next
term for next Administration uh and I
can promise you that he's already been
doing a great job of of looking at
Staffing for the next administration
because that was something that uh you
know it could have been a little bit
better in his first term obviously and
he's taking it very seriously for this
next term it could have been way better
the first time but I get it that they
were like I think Don Jr was on the show
being like you know you get in there the
first time you're like whoa we won we've
got three weeks to staff this people are
telling you pick this guy pick this guy
pick this guy and you're like I I guess
I'll go with so I I think we assumed
that you have an r in front of your name
you're on our team that's what we
thought and you know he got in there and
then he early on you learned that's not
that's not the case and so um he he
found out who his friends were he found
out who he can trust who he can put in
these positions and he's had four years
to think about it he calls this period
that we're in right now a pause period
and uh you know he he's very excited to
get back in there yeah his VP P pick is
going to be crucial it's going to be
absolutely critically important to see
his trajectory and for from my vantage
point an anti-establishment figure makes
more sense than an establishment figure
because if someone in the establishment
they're just going to take him out it's
it's quick it's easy the CIA has heart
attack guns decades and decades ago it's
guaranteed but talk a lot about this if
it's a very strong anti-establishment
person they're going to have to think
twice it has to be someone more radical
than him it has to be someone who's
willing to speak on the issues a lot
more aggressively than he is and also
kind of be different than him when it
comes to some of the things that also
divide his base you mean Tucker Carl
yes absolutely but let let talk about
where we go right now all right if Ronda
santis Michael M tweeted shout out to
Michael M he says he doesn't see how
Ronda sandz can continue if he comes in
third behind Nikki Haley there's a
little bit more context there but it's
it's an interesting question about what
happens now in New Hampshire where
supposedly she's polling at
30% I in the CNN poll yeah I don't know
if I believe St ansam has her at 22 and
Trump up 26 so um and and and in the CNN
po the 530 aggregate is 30.3% of Trump's
43.4 that's shocking are Democrats a lot
of vot Hampshire I don't know they are
and that may be and Independence uh but
they but they're expecting I mean
they're factoring an incredibly High
turnout I think the record turnout for
Democrats in a republican private is
like 35% with Democrats and Independence
I do want to just point out um man free
state project guys what are you doing
what's going on in New Hampshire voting
for Nikki Haley yikes it's a weird State
it's a great state but the way I mean
they have Governor sonunu currently as
governor and he is a rhino's Rhino and
so so do you he ended too so with that
polling I don't see Nikki Haley dropping
out I don't see Ronda SZ is pulling in
it and Nikki's got money coming in Ron's
got money running away from him what
person would be dumb enough to invest in
Ronda santis after this performance I I
I'm just man Ronda santis really just
set himself a blaze and ended his career
I just look forward to reading all the
obituaries written about his campaign
tomorrow they're going to like they're
going to he's done yeah now look he's
still within like what 17 votes of Nikki
Haley if he finishes in second he might
be able to limp on but he's going in the
wrong direction well no I mean it was
actually a little bit worse a moment ago
okay so we'll we'll see but he's down
he's down he's down we will see Trump's
already got 12 delegates they're saying
so we'll see man still but it's it's
kind of sad isn't it the promise of
Ronda santis and his governorship but I
do think it's fair to point out two
things the reason why Florida's doing so
well Everyone likes to Tribute
everything to the executive it's the
legislature Florida's got great
representatives and state senators a
ruby red State and then right when these
people pass bills Ronda sandz gets to
sign them here here's one to watch the
governor's race the gor oh Ronda Sanz
has taken second place okay wow yeah
there we go look at that now now he's
actually up by what
17 hey it could turn around for him
maybe he'll be able to but anyway
continue sorry Benny no it's just it so
now that Florida is a ruby red state
with a ton of power and then projected
power right so when the census comes the
the state will get four new
congressional seats and so forth and the
government will be insanely powerful Ron
cannot run constitutionally and that
race is already heating up in the State
of Florida as a Florida resident for
who's going to take that role you're
going to see some big names throw their
hats in what ises what does Ron do after
this I have no idea I everyone thought
well he he started this new college in
Florida called new College of Florida
and he'll it's like the new Hillsdale
College and he is that for real he will
likely appoint himself to the president
of that role can you explain to me where
Rob came from calling him Rob just to
mess with him okay yeah like and again
that's like that's something that's so
stupid but they got so upset about it
yeah the the trolling from you guys was
making them insane you got to know the
Chinese are very trolling that's the
thing it's not just the trolling
literally any even slight constructive
criticism of Ron was met with his
campaign people online diving all over
you so this is what's fascinating you
can I know Alx my executive producer
comes on the show with regularity um
great this is something that we would
this is something that we would track
all the time obviously is when we did it
it's not just trolling you said slight
trolling not even slight trolling like
constructive feedback so when something
when we didn't say something M about
like a big news story about Ronda santis
we'd get trolled so when Kim Reynolds
endorsed Ronda STIs there was a bunch of
stuff going on we didn't mention it in
our feed and the entire uh disantis Team
came scorched Earth for us like tagging
us and naming us because we didn't talk
about Rob you didn't like my post right
it's like crazy it's crazy man like
that's insane yeah so so it's not just
trolling him not even if you just didn't
talk about him acknowledging him that's
right wow it's very mean girls energy it
was very like um a Prep Prep descent
like uh High School uh acne energy I've
never seen a campaign like it in my life
I've never seen anything like it yeah so
that's my question I guess for the table
is is have we seen have we seen anything
this bad before have we ever seen a
candidate with such high hopes fall so
spectacularly Bush well Jeb well to make
to make matters worse Jeb Bush's senior
advisers were trolling around STIs two
days ago wow wow well look look Ron is
now up by no this is more spectacular 65
this is more spectacular than the jet
Bush thing Jeb actually at least was
running against the first time like the
they're running against an incumbent so
it's kind of like what's the point this
guy has got it in the bag it's a second
term know but I think the thing with
Jeb's campaign is you know the big
problem is it was Jeb in his campaign
like who's going to you know it's Jeff
Bush there so many issues with him but
when when Ron de santz and particularly
when he was first running before
everyone had this uh bad taste in their
mouth left by his his campaign um it was
like his to lose in a sense he was super
it was his campaign came and his people
just totally destroyed any momentum you
know look look for the longest time I've
I've uh not just I but many have been
talking about where are the young where
where are the Millennials to step up and
enter politics uh or even gen xers
because for the longest time we have
like what do we have like sep and
octogenarian all throughout Congress and
and the issue is I I've been saying that
it seems like for whatever reason the
millennial generation doesn't take their
role seriously doesn't they don't view
themselves as Leaders as people should
be in charge and when you look at the
Rhonda santz campaign it is the made for
home movie version of Say Home Alone
Like Home Alone one and two Classics
Ronda Sanders campaign Home Alone three
have you guys seen Home Alone 3 no what
is it it's kind of a joke hor it's kind
of a joke but I mean it has an actual
analogy in the first movie and you have
Donald Trump in the second movie one
reason I bring them up as examples it is
a highquality production with music
acting it's memorable it's an it's a
classic film Katherine O'Hara right uh
John Candy I believe right I don't know
and then that was n number one that was
number one right yeah and then in Home
Alone three it's some beist actors I
Scarlet Johansson's actually in it in
like a very small role so hey shout out
her oh no way but um it's okay the first
one is a kid gets left home Shenanigans
ensues that's about it B try to come in
he's trying to fight them off Home Alone
3 is an international band of terrorists
are stealing nuclear missile codes from
from some device of some sort and he has
to stop them but his mom is home and
it's just it's low quality it's garbage
when when uh uh so now that I've made
the silly joke I've mentioned this when
when Barack Obama watch his announcement
speech when he's announcing that he's
running for president back in what was
it like end of 07 or or 08 or whatever I
don't even remember he's standing in
front of a crowd of 10 20,000 people and
he does this very charismatic thing
where he goes and that is why I Barack
Obama am running for the United States
and and then the crowd just goes they're
screaming it's this historic moment
Ronda santis announces his candidacy on
a crashing Twitter space going well I'm
here to lead the Great American comeback
and that was it and it cut out we
couldn't get we couldn't hear it there's
no video there's no crowd there's no
rally there is no historical moment
other than the failure of it it's so
poorly done also Luke I like I need that
I need that notepad for to to to play
out exactly what Ronda santis did
because I was listening to it the first
one crashed then they restarted the
space did you join the second space did
anybody he listen to the second space so
the second space what you hear is the
actual that space didn't crash and you
hear Rhonda santis reading from a
notepad oh yeah uh his speech which fine
read a speech most politicians do read
speeches but you don't do that on a
Twitter space yeah you're stupid why
would you do that on Twitter like why
don't you even understand the medium
you're talking on so I'm going on Tim
pool IRL that's the show I'm on right
now cast timcast IRL and why would I
like what what you don't do on this show
is play a xylophone right and that's not
I mean not late night on
Friday Fray yeah got
one% why don't you study the medium that
you're on but he just started into a
scripted speech it made no sense I was
like he's he's done he's doomed I was
listening to it in our kitchen with my
wife and I was like he's doomed it's
over like we played it on air team
santis is claiming the election is
rigged who what Jeremy Redford I'm at a
Precinct that hasn't even voted yet and
the media is trying to call the race for
Trump so they're
well
so it was weird to see Trump at 1% this
is his official press secretary from his
official office and you know there's
ethics issues but we're not going to
here's the tweet I am at a pre that
hasn't even voted yet and the media are
trying to call the race for Trump
happens all the times yeah happens all
the time right it's the only 3%
reporting actually especially in states
with different time zones so like the
the other half of the state if a time
zone splits in a state like you you
you'll call the state and half State
hasn't even voted yet but that happens
uh oh this is this a tweet from Wesley
hunt getting attacked yeah oh wow let me
uh you you tweet or wesy hun tweeted
this yeah is it violent uh I didn't
watch it the way
through Let's uh let's pull up this clip
here we go ladies and gentlemen this is
a tweet from Wesley hunt let me slow
down here great dude by the way he says
tonight at the Timberline caucus as I
spoke on behalf of President Trump an
enraged man attempted to stop my speech
he shouted Trump was racist you know the
same Tire Trum we heard over and over
but on this day of all days Martin
Luther King Day the people of Iowa just
like President Trump Judge Me Not by the
color of my skin but by the content of
my character the anti-trump movement is
in full-blown meltdown so let me uh
let's uh play this now is the smartest
most genius M 4 minutes minute clip do
we know what what yeah about a minute
and a half in minute and a half and this
is from someone on the disantis team
they say he was a disantis
supporter now I'm a military guy by
trade come from military family my dad's
retired Colonel my went to West Point
first in my family I went to West Point
my brother went to West Point there are
60 years the fames
he rushes the court today today
today
today about
[Music]
[Applause]
RAC do this
on wow what did he
[Music]
say so so how do you know this guy is
connected to disantis I'll just say this
was a text I got he said a disantis
supporter he said how could you do this
on Martin Luther King Jr day or
something like that it's like is that a
is that a white
guy no no that's that's not no this guy
right here it's know sorry I mean me and
Sheamus had more serious arguments than
that I'm saying they went at each other
I just I don't see skin color is the guy
is the guy who's yelling at Wesley also
a black man he appears to be right I I
can't you it's hard it's hard to
tell but is that his point that Wesley
Hunt is betraying Martin Luther King or
whatever or something like this but how
who knows for supporting Trump okay he
said something that bothered the
audience but we missed it it was a
little bit before well he say how how
dare you he's racist or something like
that shout out to Martin Luther King
let's uphold his well I think he's
getting a lot of flack right now I think
the important thing to recognize too
is there's a lot of people at history
people need to know the the truth about
and and if you don't really pay
attention uh you might just believe the
simple things of them a good a good
example is like Shay guara like that
dude was like a really bad guy but young
people just wear his shirt all the time
cuz they pay attention that being said
Marth Lu King Jr had had some great
points but uh I'm not going to sit here
and try and adjudicate the whole debate
that's been going on but a big thing
happening right now is criticism of MLK
over a lot of the stuff that he was
involved in I don't know I don't know
enough about it I know the FBI knows
about it since they were spying on him
and then uh recording his private
conversations with his Mistresses and
then playing it to his wife when he was
in jail trying to of course get them
divorced as of course a court in t in
Memphis actually found the US government
complicit in the assassination of MLK
well take a look at this from uh it's on
Twitter on X the the FBI tweeted this
MLK Day the FBI honors one of the most
prominent leaders of the civil rights
movement and reaffirms its commitment to
Dr King's Legacy of fairness and equal
justice for all there's a community note
that reads the FBI engaged in
surveillance of King attempted to
discredit him and used manipulation
tactics to influence him to stop
organizing King's family believed the
FBI was responsible for his death so
shout out to community on x believe
there was an actual court case in
Memphis in 1999 that looked at all the
evidence and a jury found the US
government complicit in the
assassination of MLK they paid a civil
fee I think they they won they won $100
but the one $100 was just uh for the
court proceedings to kind of move
forward I got I got some bad news for
you Alex Ron's actually pulled ahead of
Nikki by by a good amount well we'll see
what happens as long as Nikki loses
tonight I'll be happy uh otherwise I I
kind of really don't care the idea of
anyone losing to Nikki Haley is just so
depressing a poor viic I I honestly it
even makes me sad to see Chris Christie
lose to Nikki like well there's only one
there's only one winner and that's
whoever gets the most so that's there's
no everyone's a loser except for djt at
this rate the the FBI first you're last
just don't want to let this slip the FBI
pre-wrote the suicide note for MLK is
that correct y yep and they were
encouraging him to take his own life
when he was going through a difficult
time yep they letters they sent letters
saying you got to off yourself you got
to kill yourself you're a horrible
person because of so and so signed FBI
or what signed fake no no the FBI
literally was running scops on MLK where
do I know this the FBI's own files so
the FBI has released these files and
they've like they're available on the
FBI website you and the agents who did
this were never held accountable so this
was the beginning stages of the FBI
under Jay Edgar Hoover who also uh was a
person who's probably being extorted as
well for the dresses that he was wearing
but but but but that's the start of the
FBI what are they doing now RFK Jr was
just asked about the the wire tapping
recently and he defended JFK and R
wiretapping of MLK wow and so yeah he's
he's in a he said he needed to do it
yeah why which is crazy he's he's in a
tough spot he's he's but why did he
think there's something strange
happening to RF J I don't know what's
happening to RF Jun but there has been a
huge turnaround in his in his in his
kind of team that is very kind of
bewildering uh he was
admittedly um and we found this out
through the documents but before the
documents came out he said he was on the
Lolita Express which with Jeffrey
Epstein and his wife all the way back in
the early
1990s um and that's what he admitted to
his father was attorney general
overseeing the FBI's operations and so
he's being asked to defend his late
father right I suppose would be the
what's actually going on JFK Jr RFK Jr
is being asked to defend his father's
actions he must have signed off on this
you'd have to assume I mean I don't know
but you'd have to assume in some level
his father knew about what they were
doing MLK and so RFK Jr in a tough spot
I mean it's your it's your dad who met
his own untimely demise I mean obviously
you know tragically and horrifically so
it's like probably at the hands of the
Intel agencies they said it was Siran
Siran some Wild guy in a kitchen but
fellas I do have to bounce all right man
celebrate a victory and uh appreciate
you hanging outs as you can see very
close we we we uh we're are wait we are
waiting hopefully the vake can come by
she's going to be here in a few minutes
according to uh text that I've been
receiving a few minutes I false hope but
8 I think 8:15 was the call time but
we'll see we'll see everything 815 was
the call time yeah so one minute ago he
he's to V's credit between the three
candidates that are behind Trump right
now he significantly spent less money
and is probably overperforming that his
predictions were early in the cycle and
and and also Nikki Haley's voters a lot
of them probably Democrats yep so you
know I don't even consider her votes to
be actual she not convincing anybody but
Democratic party to vote for Nikki
Hillary the also worked very hard um
hitting the ground game here more than I
think anyone else so it's crazy you know
when Ronda Santos does an event and he
meets people the people that he meets
typically don't like him V kind of is
charismatic and he has something called
Riz these video what's this video with
the guy the guy in the wheelchair
getting thrown out of the dis what was
that so this there there's a a meme team
it's called the Dilly meme team and this
guy in a wheelchair showed up at a
disantis event wearing a Dilly meme Team
hat and because he didn't like his hat
he got rolled out of the and then
there's the other guy Matt Kim is that
his name yeah he got kicked out as well
got Ki out too these guys didn't do
anything they just showed up and
obviously they're critical of Dan santis
on the interweb and man I kind of wish I
went to those events I texted you two
photos from a from the caucus event of
of Nikki Haley voters and so you can
give people sort of a an image of I I
have they we have a production team here
and they're at they're at do can you
tweet them I can't pull them from my
phone screen y if you tweet them out
yourself I'll pull up your Twitter okay
God bless you all all right man thanks
for hanging out I suppose if uh whoever
is waiting in the wings wants to jump on
while we're waiting for vake unless it's
here you guys want to rock paper
scissors for it Jos right here Spruce
Switz ladies and gentlemen Josie the
redheaded libertarian is jumping in Jo
how's it going I'm going to pull up
Benny Johnson's Twitter I'm tweeting it
right now he's tweeting it right now
what's your analysis uh Josie on
everything yeah you're sitting there
watching grab that mic talk to us I just
want Nikki to lose tonight amen well I
think we're good I think I think uh if
anything is worth celebrating it's her
defeat and I and look there is there is
a funny thing about watching Ronda
Sanders lose to Nikki Haley but I really
want Nikki Haley to come in fourth I
just want everyone to be like nobody
wants her get out of here is this
because people are genuinely concerned
that Trump will be taken off ballot
somehow like are people do is that
actually like I mean it's not rhetorical
question but like is it what what do you
mean the threat that Trump will either
be removed legally no I know but what do
you think would like what would that
explain then the next runner up would be
the the the number one candidate the
front runner for the Republican ticket
Cassandra Fairbanks had another tweet
too we have these images that were
showing of these Nikki Haley voters and
it was a guy with a peace sign tattoo
voting for Nikki Haley and Cassandra uh
McDonald you know she she works here
she's great she was just like how are
you so dumb like Nikki Haley is the
warmonger candidate like what do you
think some own old Boomer Democrat with
a pece tattoo from their hippie days
yeah and now they're in the uh corporate
chill days I guess unfortunately yeah
but look you know if uh if if Nikki
loses which he's going to she there's no
way she's winning then uh we all have
reason to celebrate I guess but it is
what it is just say you're a misogynist
him goodness that's right well I suppose
hoping uh Pops in in a moment let's talk
about this story here we have this from
Taylor Hansen uh tenant media shout out
he tweets as I'm on my way home to Salt
Lake City Utah I noticed six illegal
immigrants are also boarding the same
American Air flight looks like I've got
some new neighbors I want to pull up uh
I'll pull up the twet maybe they maybe
they've pinned it I don't know where uh
okay tenant's covering all the caucus
stuff there's a video that oh holy crap
Iran is allegedly launched an attack on
a US Consulate in Iraq is it well th
those were the original reports but the
Iran are now saying that they're
attacking a rebel group that is against
Iran inside of Iraq so far we have not
gotten any confirmations that us targets
were uh picked out here w wow great oh
and for Vi was hitting another caucus
site so he may be much later if they
well we have this story from tenant
media this is crazy we should definitely
talk about this pertaining to the uh us
elections last night tenant reporter
Taylor USA confronted multiple satx
police working a side gig where they're
helping facilitate human smuggling at
the migrant Resource Center in San
Antonio Texas the officers are seen
wearing their official sapd uniforms
driving work vehicles and holstering
their service weapons while accepting
money from alleged cartel sponsored NOS
to guard the facility and check illegal
migrants wristbands upon entry we tended
to reach out to satx police for comment
on the situation and received no
response the story is massive it's got
2.3 million views just on the single
tweet alone and this is what I was
talking about the fear of what happens
when law enforcement is f is is
committing crimes what happens
these are these are what is it San
Antonio police using police and publicly
funded Vehicles weapons and and and and
equipment to help facilitate cartel
alleged cartel human smuggling
operations we got that report just uh
last week the doj is suing Texas because
Texas deployed armed soldiers to block
CBP access to the river you now have a
bubbling conflict between corrupt law
enforcement facilitating human
trafficking and smuggling and law
enforcement at the state level trying to
stop it where does that
go I I I defer to the states the states
have a duty to defend themselves right
but what do you think happens if the
federal government doesn't back down and
what do you think happens if Nick Haley
wins it's interesting conundrum for the
federal government hopefully their their
their goal is to support states rights
ideally is is cohesion and you don't
want to press the states away and also
they're dealing with geopolitical
nightmare with this like you're talking
about the houthis what's going on in
Ukraine and Israel all these things hope
hopefully the United States has not push
the issue on this I mean Texas made very
clear okay what does that mean the
United States they are actively
facilitating human smuggling into this
country and have been for several years
the charts show that it is there's no
way it's an accident the rates are
double triple or quadruple what they
were under Trump and under Obama so it's
on purpose and the only state doing
anything somewhat is Texas while the
other states do nothing kind of made me
think about the American Civil War I was
thinking about the Emancipation
Proclamation and how Abraham Lincoln was
was like Hey all you slaves in the South
you're free and kind of like and by the
way if you want to fight for the north
go for it all these illegal immigrants
if the federal government were like hey
all the all you illegal immigrants you
can have citizenship if you want to
fight for the federal government if you
know what I mean kind of thing like if
there's a just to like disincentivize
people from trying to create some sort
of Civil War in the United States we
talk about this quite a bit on the show
but we have you here Benny I'm curious
your thoughts on the on this border
issue right you've got state level
fighting with Federal officers to the
point where they're armed soldiers
deployed against Federal law
enforcement so all of this goes back to
the 1960s cloward and Piven and the
Communists who sort of wrote The
neo-marxist Vision for America and how
to bring Marxism to America and one of
the number one things you needed to do
was uh balloon the welfare state large
enough so that it actually collapses the
federal dollar and the federal
government's capacity that's that's the
number one way to create crisis America
would never be conquered this was after
World War II so how do you actually
bring down a behemoth like America how
do you bring down the you know the Beast
that is America you have to destroy it
from within you have to give it a a some
type of uh horrible malady and something
that is so insufferable that it can't
move forward and so their idea was swell
the welfare roles which you saw with the
Great Society program uh swell the
welfare roles so big that the federal
government can never afford it and then
that will create of course the
millstones of high taxation and
inflation that that grind the middle
class and you get no middle class
and so this the way that you swell the
welfare rules is to bring people here
that have that don't speak the language
that have no skills um that can't get
jobs or are having a tough time you know
or or can't work legally uh but are
accessible are able to get on welfare
programs and California is leading the
way in this and that's the way that you
actually collapse the United States of
America I think that's the ultimate
strategy here a lot of people are like
well they'll vote Democrat I think F yes
maybe yes but the real goal is the
collapse of the country as we know it
and that was the vision set out by the
theorists the com the Marxist theorists
neo-marxist theorists who Barack Obama
are the acolyte is the acolyte of do you
think that they're making this decision
to let these people in on accident that
it's like toxically compassionate or are
they actively trying to destroy the
country it's not compassionate it's
child smuggling this is the most
horrific thing that a man a human being
can do to another human being I it's
awful What's happen I guess but once
they hit the Border they're like at this
point they're here the idea that like
well we can't turn them away that that
kind of like why can't you turn them
away I mean you can but another country
every other country in the World Turns
away I mean go check out the border with
with Egypt and Gaza but but it's but
it's not just that and that is true the
Egypt and Gaza is a great example it's
not just that it's a uh why the US
doesn't pay Ransom to terrorists in the
Middle East it it it is it is well known
for the most part I don't know Biden may
have changed some of this that if you
are traveling around I don't know Syria
or something and you get kidnapped and
you're an American citizen the people
who kidnapped you know the US doesn't
pay they send a bunch of heavily armed
dudes from from a Blackhawk in the
middle of the night to kill you and
anyone in the building with you but
European countries will pay the ransoms
instantly what happens if you're Spanish
or German you're a huge Target you if
you're a journalist from Spain or
Germany a national and you're traveling
around the Middle East they are looking
at you you you cost $4 million they know
like that's the guy to get then there's
an American next to him they're go not
that guy you they'll just kill you if if
us is basically saying borders open if
you're here I guess you're here what
happens some dude in Honduras goes well
if I go there they'll let me in might as
well go if the if the strategy was we've
blocked it off turn around good luck
you're on your own not our problem guy
in Honduras be like there's no point in
traveling A Thousand Miles they're going
to turn me away that's why I call it
toxically compassionate it's not real
it's like compassion to a fault like we
can let everyone in it'll be okay it's
not compassion it's the opposite of that
and and to Tim's point the CIA usually
gives the money upfront to the
terrorists um and and then that's
usually how they get their cut they
don't rely on uh on on on you know
killing people and and and kidnapping
them they just get the money up front uh
but but but if you look at what what's
happening here again this is a
deliberate plot here this is a
deliberate plan to not just create
future Democratic voters but there's a
larger bigger agenda here that has been
weaponized against the American people
that is causing division that is causing
strife I think a lot of this is planned
I think they're trying to get as much of
it done before this next election cycle
because they know this is going to be
one of the key issues that they're going
to be recalled for and when they do they
want to make sure they have enough
people here for whatever reason some
people say we need military fighting age
males to fight China or Russia some
people are saying we might need these
males to fight the other faction inside
of the United States may be a part of
take a drink Civil War that could
potentially happen as well there's
theories out there but the theories are
legitimate because it's not for the
benefit of the American people in any
way you you kind of look at it there the
possibility that the Biden
Administration invokes the Insurrection
act against Texas for blocking federal
agents at the border uh I would defer to
the constitution on this so it's the
federal government's job article 4
section 4 uh article one section 8 of
the US Constitution to protect the
states from Invasion however when you
jump to the 10th Amendment the 10th
Amendment says that if the federal
government is failing their own
responsibility and the article doesn't
say that the States cannot be can cannot
take up the responsibility then that
responsibility can be taken up by the
states or by the individuals and that's
that's really key I think that we're
going to start seeing some some really
interesting what if under that argument
of section article 4 section 4 the Biden
administ Administration says we are
protecting the Border by having our
troops our our our CBP and our our law
enforcement at the border and Texas is
blocking us from enforcing our
constitutional duties thus engaging in
Insurrection uh Ken Paxton has an 80%
win rate against the Biden
Administration so he's pretty pretty
probably one of the smartest people in
the Constitution that I've ever come
across so yeah but we're not talking
about the like the legality of it Norms
are breaking down the idea that the
Texas National Guard was deployed armed
to block access to federal law
enforcement the concern there is at what
point do both sides assert jurisdiction
over the same area and when that happens
who's going to try to arrest the other
or or does this really just come down to
Biden Administration just backs down
instantly and say says we don't want to
fight we lose you win this is exactly
what happened in Fort
suner that kickoff kick kicked off the
Civil War like an argument over a
military base where like a localized
militia like started fighting federal
forces the Union forces were occupying
Fort Suter the after the secession South
Carolina said you are not welcome to be
here leave the Union forces were like
it's our base we built and paid for you
can't seced it's illegal we're staying
and I think the only actual death in
that conflict was an accidental death on
the side of the Union I could be wrong
uh his I read a bunch of Articles saying
no one really knows who fired the first
shot but I'm simply saying territorial
dispute Federal jurisdiction is what
kicked off the Civil War like what is
seen as historically kicked off here but
here's here's the best point after that
we historically look back at that date
and say that was the start of the Civil
War however the actual first bloody
battle was the first battle of BU run
which even after the battle at Fort
Suter local residents in the area did
not believe Civil War could happen even
though we believe it already started and
we picnicking watching the first bloody
battle which was chaos so we look at
this border issue this jurisdiction
issue and perhaps that's it perhaps all
we get is a standoff which is happening
now already with federal law enforcement
Texas National Guard and we think
nothing of it and even after some CBP
guy shoves a National Guard guy and then
they try arresting someone and we're
like wow they're fighting we still don't
think we're in it and then maybe after
this Texas deploys armed National Guard
to the border to block a bunch of Biden
vehicles that are trying to come in
resulting in actual shootouts and then
we say 100 years from now it started
when the Texas National Guard deployed
armed soldiers to block federal agents
from facilitating human smuggling or
whatever so here's what I I see so in
the
Constitution the federal government's
jurisdiction over the border is
literally just the naturalization
process that's it that's all that's
written in there for them is the
naturalization process so it would say
you know for that instance that the
states would be in charge of everything
else except for when there is an
invasion so I I think what they could do
is they would have to declare an
invasion the federal government would
have to say well there's an invasion now
and then they they' go in there they'd
send their troops in and handle it by
just continuing to do all the
that they're
doing the the difference of the Civil
War in the 1860s and now is internet
video because we're not passively
watching stuff happen we are crafting it
as we go like how don't know how many
people are watching right now 50,000
people 000 yeah like the the the amount
of Consciousness that can be tweaked by
our conversation literally is is never
in the human history has and maybe
that's like part of this desperation of
this time in human history is that we
have this internet video for this
purpose to repurpose to create Mass
formation in like a a good way I I
disagree um we may be reaching our live
concurrent audience between like 80 and
83,000 individuals but shortly you know
20 years ago it was Millions for these
very limited networks and the only
difference is the geography of the
viewers so if you go back to the 1860s
people would be saying the same thing
wow we can reach a 100,000 people with
the printing press instantly who would
have ever thought we could influence so
many people by printing papers rapidly
on these machines and distributing but
the issue was GE geography so the people
in these areas you could reach 100,000
by circulating papers we're circulating
this show to you know it'll probably end
up being like a million people but
they're spread out so the big
differences whereas with the uh uh Civil
War in this country in the 1860s it's
Geographic it's north and south so yes
ideas are being spread in those isolated
areas now you're going to have pockets
all over the country of different
factions and that's what we see in other
countries and have seen in other civil
wars I think though you know long
distance is free now you can make phone
calls you can do video chats with your
friends in out of state the diaspora is
is it's very clear and and 20 30 years
ago this show would have been shut down
15 minutes in because of what we were
talking talking about like the ability
to like go right at the situation and
describe it to people is they they it
was called golden handcuffs and that's a
common phrase what would happen 20 years
ago if you on like a cable network
channel and you had a panel show where
they expected you to say you know Nikki
Hale is the best or something like that
and you went off the rails they would
let the show happen and then later they
would tell you hey you know we're we're
actually going to move your time slot
but we don't know exactly what we're
going to do so we'll let you know you're
under contract you can't quit they're
paying you a lot of monies a lot of
money but you you can't produce any
content golden handcuffs they they
they'll they'll sign you for a few years
then they'll tell you to wait if you try
and produce anything else they'll sue
you they tried it with Tucker Carlson
taking his show off the air but then
saying you're under contract you can't
do any work and he said try me yeah back
in the day without Twitter he'd be gone
and he couldn't and here's the issue
Tucker gets the ax from Fox News if this
was 20 years ago what's he going to do
he go to CBS they'd say we can't hire
you we'll get sued by Fox he goes Ms we
can't hire you we'll get sued by Fox
today he goes I'll make my own content
on Twitter and then fox says we'll sue
you and he goes go for it he would the
other networks would have basically just
teamed up with Fox and locking him up
and preventing his voice from being
heard so in in that regard I will I
agree with you this is something new and
Powerful that's breaking that Dynamic
that being said that that control that
they had back then that was something to
behold they could snap their fingers and
have 100 million people believe the most
crazy nonsense instantly and they've
lost that power or they're losing it
yeah it's really wild to look at the
centralized control of the free networks
that you would get even if you had a TV
you didn't have to pay for ABC NBC or
CBS it just comes standard with the TV
in every American household and PBS I
suppose you can include that and how
every single every single night they
were all on message it was absolute
government programming like my childhood
of course was in the 80s and that was
just pure government programming all
news yeah this is something new this
ability for the human to tell you what I
think that's yeah it's it's not to be
trifled with it's it's we should respect
it and use it to its ultimate Luke was
that like the Zenith of operation
Mockingbird right would like would be
like
1987 where every anchor was on message
where every Outlet was free and
broadcast directly into a million
households that was an operation
Mockingbird there was other
Congressional hearings that actually did
find out that there was CIA agents at
the top of almost every uh major news
outlet that were pretty much uh calling
the shots and directing uh people to
publish news that the CIA wanted them to
publish now we're seeing a different
kind of version of it with these same
kind of intelligence agencies
influencing social media and the
algorithms and what people can and
cannot say on those particular platforms
so they they changed the way that they
do things um and instead of just going
to these Network heads I think they're
still at the network I think they're
just just expanding where the media and
information is expanding and what we're
getting now other than uh in lied way
kind of Rumble and Twitter is is curated
content that I think they centrally
control in more ways than one that we
even don't understand as of yet just how
sophisticated their manipulation of
information is as now so uh to to answer
your question they manipulated the CIA
manipulated what we saw before and now
they're doing it again uh with the
exception of uh um Twitter and Rumble
which are directly under attack by the
establishment right now so I I think
this is why
um there's such a fervent fight to take
those institutions down because then
when they're down the establishment
could pretty much do whatever they want
to us um but now that they're up I think
this is one of the big things that is
stopping a big kind of event a big kind
of October surprise and a lot of the
same old tactics were changed up so when
we have the next big thing to deal with
when we have the next big scop it's
going to be far more complicated than
what we're used to dealing with and have
many layers to it where even our
reaction uh being skeptical of it could
be playing along with the larger game
against us as well so I'm trying to
think of this as as how they're playing
all this out how could they get away
with this because they are very maniacal
they do think many steps ahead of us and
they do try to control and limit what we
can and cannot listen to let's let's let
me pull up this story and speaking of
what Luke is talking about it's a tweet
from NBC News a network of public
interest groups and lawmakers nervous
about former president Trump's potential
return to power is quietly devising
plans to foil any effort on his part to
pressure the US military to carry out
his political agenda so quiet sounds
like a conspiracy news it's it's I mean
I guess the only reason we wouldn't call
it a conspiracy is that they're publicly
admitting they're doing it yeah exactly
yeah I'd said earlier that we've seen
this one before it was the Time magazine
article after 2020 after that election
it was a very similar headline about how
they save the election with a shadow
government the shadow campaign to save
the election if you click on El if you
click on the article could see NBC News
trying to justify this by uh fearing
that Trump is is a danger to democracy
so they're making the argument therefore
we have to take down Trump uh in order
to save uh our government which which is
absolutely ridiculous I think it's in
the comments of the original tweet but
it's amuse which is at amuse and he says
the person behind it is uh Mary mcord
Yep this one he says reminder the woman
behind the coup planning report on NBC
is Mary B McCord who served as the
acting assistant AG for National
Security from October 2016 to 17 you may
recall that she reviewed and approved
FIS of warrants to suril Carter page of
former Trump campaign Aid the fisa court
which approved these warrants in 16 17
later criticized government officials
for providing false and misleading
information about paage and the infamous
steel dossier mord has mentioned in the
Justice Department Inspector General
report which identified significant
errors and omissions in the FBI's
applications for warrants to surveil
page mcord approved the fraudulent fisa
applications against paage later mcord
was appointed to advise the foreign
intell surveillance Court as as an
amicus Cur curer as I pronounce it her
role involves providing advice and
expertise on matters related to foreign
intelligence collection today she is
organizing the effort to strip Trump of
his power as commander-in-chief so um is
that a coup yeah that's a coup uh she
sounds like uh I wouldn't call her the
queen of the swamp but maybe like a
princess of the deep State uh this this
woman here um and you know that's what
they have they kind of dip into they
have their their group of deep State and
then they just dip into them and put
them in different positions all over the
government so she's she's one of them so
some somebody to watch for dictatorial
ways Trump will use his military if he
returns to the White House Their Fear is
it's not the military I mean there's two
things I think their fear of his use of
the military is going to be withdrawing
forces and not engaging in this liberal
economic order stuff but then I think
their big fear also is the criminal
prosecution of them their corrupt
actions they took in 2016 and uh I got
to say that may mean that Donald Trump
has information that may lead to the
arrest of Hillary Clinton I don't know
if any information will ever lead to the
arrest of Hillary
Clinton yeah I did like that he walked
back the retribution uh rhetoric a few
days ago I think it was two or three
days ago he mentioned that he wants to
focus on building something great in the
future and coming together and you know
maybe too little too late he's already
been pretty plaintive that he wants to
go I don't know what he said exactly but
harass the get back I don't know if he
what he wants to do I don't know what he
wants to do this story is a kind of huge
huge admission here because they're
saying we're quietly working to subvert
Donald Trump if he becomes the president
of the United States they're not being
very quiet about it exactly they're
they're they're they're kind of uh you
know telling publicly declaring that
they're doing they're arrogant about it
so so um again this also brings it
question who's really in charge if
you're the president of the United
States is it the bureaucracy that's
embedded within Washington DC is it a
deep State as of course they're trying
to solidify decisions before Trump is
even in office before he even makes them
and to give Trump some credit here yell
Harari the the second in command to
pretty much CLA Schwab a head guy at the
world economic Forum you all uh I'll
call him whatever I want to call Hees
I'll call it whatever I want Russell
Brand could could kiss him all he wants
I'm not gonna be be kissing his butt
here y Harari came out and said that if
Trump is elected that he will be dealing
the death blow to the global order those
are major statements made by yoel and
it's a statement y y and they are very
indicative to to
actually think it's extremely important
people know the Guy's real name is juval
Harari whatever youall knowah Harari the
Time magazine article actually goes on
to list everybody involved because they
were you know had to celebrate and
congratulate each other it says there
was a conspiracy unfolding behind the
scenes whoa big batch of votes just
jumped in right awayes from 4% to 26% in
the New York Times Ronda sand is still
in second place with 5,824 Nikki Haley
with 5,450 v Rami with 2274 percentages
have all remained relatively stable yep
Chris Chris has 13 now wow he got 10 I
don't know if he can afford to fly all
those people out for dinner but yeah
it's a lot he's got a lot of weeks he'll
just have dinner 4 13 people well Josie
I want to follow along with what you
were saying yeah any other Tuesday you
know all right I'll do that again all
right so there was a conspiracy
unfolding behind the scenes one that
both curtailed the protest and
coordinated the resistance from CEOs
both surprises were the result of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists in business Titans The Pact
was formalized in a tur little noticed
joint statement of the US Chamber of
Commerce and the AFL CIO published on
Election Day both sides would come to
see it as some sort of implicit bargain
inspired by The Summer's massive
sometimes destructive racial Justice
protests in which the forces of Labor
came together with the forces of capital
to keep the peace and oppose Trump's
assault on Democracy wow wow I wonder I
wonder if they called the race for Trump
because all the reporters at the
precincts just saw a bunch of people
wearing Trump signs chanting Trump over
and over again and they're like a he won
it's it's it his yeah mhm yeah so it was
a handshake between business and labor
is what they're saying so that's that's
the Deep State when did that happen uh
that was 2020 it was right after the
election Time Magazine posted they
actually you know it says a packed how I
read it was a packed it actually used to
say cabal cabal cabal and they went in
and fixed that I think they took that
word out that youv all Noah Harari said
that about Trump that he's the biggest
threat to the New Order is that how he
how he worded it the new he will deal
the death blow to the global order that
was you all though yeah this is youv all
know Harari the death blow the the world
order so this these World economic Forum
people are trying to build a new world
order out of our liberal economic order
so so this is this is what happens uh
they create the liberal economic order
it you can read it on their own websites
on the CFR website they talk about the
creation of the liberal economic order
it's the financial systems that they
have in place it's Swift it's IMF it's
the World Bank Etc and then in you you
end up with this viral video of George
HW Bush saying we can begin to see a new
world order new world order goes from
being just a descriptive like an
adjective on world order into a specific
proper phrase the New World Order which
becomes a conspiracy theory but what I
think really happens is when people
started correctly pointing out that
these powerful individuals were trying
to develop a new type of liberal
economic order what they did was they
insert lies this is one way to control
when people are getting too close to the
truth is you take control
of the movement of the of the theories
of the anger and steer them in the wrong
direction so then New World Order
becomes some weird conspiracy theory
they start injecting fake ideas into it
to distract everybody and then New World
Order turns into a conspiracy theory
phrase that becomes rather mean
meaningless to the average person and
they dismiss it outright like globalist
that was another word globalist the
globalist they said that was an
anti-semitic slur and really what it is
is what it looks like is a bunch of PE
like International corporations and the
people that run them and The Intern
monetary system and banking system out
of Switzerland I don't know if it's only
out Switzerland like Davos they me it
Davos it's a lot of these people you
consider globalists because they don't
adhere to any one country's laws um it's
it's definitely concerning I think that
youv all is not wrong Donald Trump I
don't know if it would be a death blow
but he would be a twist of fate and it
would it would prevent create a new type
of challenge to this uh handing over of
American Wealth this 35 trillion that
we've printed the 1.6 they just
authorized Congress to use next year 1.6
trillion
that money I mean going to the Ukraine a
lot of it went to the Ukraine yep it's
it's it's it feels like it's being
siphoned that that the United States is
being siphoned out they're done with
this husk of a country to lead the world
order they want to do some new country
or new probably corporations run the New
World Order I think is probably the the
uh recipe of the day you guys ever see
those fake viral videos that are super
annoying where it's his family and
they're walking on piles of $100 bills
there's like there's a video of them and
a big tractor trailer full of like just
probably $50 million and $100 bills and
it's pouring out and they're throwing it
in the air it's a really annoying thing
it's on Instagram because people will
watch it because they think it's real
it's fake but someone took one of these
videos and the Elon Musk parody account
posted you know breaking secret uh
Insider footage from zelinsky's home and
they're walking through just piles and
piles of $100 bills and money just
thrown all over the place because uh I
think that's how we actually view what's
going on with Ukraine whe whether it's
actually zsky or just a money vacuum to
steal our cash to fund it a waste of
time like I don't know if we can stop it
man this is part of what concerns me I
I'm not going to scream no you know
there's better ways to twist and
jiujitsu the energy away from the
creation of something you hate then to
scream no but like what I mean do you
guys I'd love to hear your thoughts well
uh they did just say that Switzerland's
going to broker or they asked
Switzerland and China was it is that
right to broker a deal with Ukraine to
broker peace well the specific news
article is z Linsky asking uh
Switzerland if there they could hold
peace talks and involve China in it
that's the specific news report that all
right so that that means hopefully
hopefully this is the end of the Ukraine
war and sending them money I mean
ideally if I want to be an optimist
maybe the end but then what will happen
is if black if they use Black Rock to
try and rebuild the country you might
end up seeing American money go to to
the rebuilding of the Ukraine too oh you
will regardless no matter what happens
it's going to be more American money for
the rebuilding of Ukraine and it's not
really you might consider it American
money because we the taxpayers have to
suffer as a result of the siphoning but
you know uh you might also argue that
it's Global money on loan to us like the
Federal Reserve loans us promissary
notes they don't that's in 1913 man they
took our our ability to create our own
money away from us and gave it to this
quasi private company called the Federal
Reserve that gives us promiser notes
that we'll promise to pay them their
their money back so all this US dollar
stuff is just confiscated the gold Benny
Johnson's got a bounce I've got a bounce
he's taking off we got a whole team here
and we got to go we got thanks for
coming in we're uh we're just uh I'm
sending messages back and forth and V's
team just says give us a few minutes
give a give us a few minutes and it's
they're they're an hour behind but I
can't blame them they're running to
caucus it is what it is but Benny I will
leave you here to fight the new
globalist world neocon order thanks man
of I will join you at any time we do
have Phil is one of the best YouTube
channels on Earth please subscribe and
then please also subscribe to Benny
Johnson thanks for hanging out man oh
always a pleasure
great to see you guys that was fun Phil
leonti is going to jump in he's been
sitting there waiting good cuz he's got
the and uh in in about 10 minutes we're
going to jump to I I will'll call them
the uh physical super chats of the
people hanging out who want to ask
questions to everybody we got hanging
out uh there were several uh politicians
who were slated to stop by who did not
make it unfortunately I'm not surprised
though considering the weather which
kind of sucks but it is what it is we
came down and uh the of course was uh
supposed to be here
7:45 and uh you know what what what are
you going to do about it he's out
campaigning trying to get people to
caucus for him it is what it is it be
what it do and
uh uh okay it sounds like he's not
coming oh so is that he's not coming he
is not coming oh well I'm I'm not
surprised I'm GNA be completely honest
coming in fourth place with 7.7% after
all the work he did I don't know what he
would be doing right now anyway how many
vot how many how many of the votes are
in with 37% of the votes in Donald Trump
with 22,000 Ron with 8 8,5 Nick with 81
right behind him and VI Rami with
3,259 so I kind of figured this might
might be uh that's unfortunate well I
mean yeah I thought it was going to be a
victory speech for him I hoping he'd be
perhaps he was thinking he was going to
do better and now his priorities are not
incoming on a live show to talk about
how he's actually losing I mean I I
agree and I I get it but at the same
time I mean I guess maybe this is just
looking the bread said he beat Chris
Christie and Chris Christie's you know a
well-known name he's hard to beat yeah
it's true run at at at you know politics
and stuff could you could you imagine
chrisy actually trying to come out here
and go to all the
districts the memes I don't think
anybody worked as hard as VI did in
order to uh uh you know get the the
amount of support that he did so that's
admirable look VI was trying to convince
Trump trump supporters to vote for him
yeah that's that's a ridiculous
proposition in the long run the plan
Plan B strategy makes sense he's waiting
in the wings he's the bench for 2028 or
something like that I like the idea but
going to Trump trump supporters and
saying save Trump by voting for me is
just like it is come on man it's just
not going to work especially this early
uh you know he's still got a ways until
he starts actually having to show up in
court and stuff like that so there's
still you know it's not set in stone
that he's not going to be on the ballot
although I mean personally I I think
that it's likely that there'll be a lot
of efforts to keep off the ballot and
whatever they can do they'll do but I I
don't think that it's compelling to the
average voter cuz I think the average
Trump supporter is currently still
thinking he's GNA he's going to be able
to beat the charges you know I I I
wonder what the so when we were planning
this whole thing out the original idea
was to come just for today and uh we
ultimately decided because of the debate
with uh vake we would do this town hall
and you know have him on and so it ended
up working out really really really well
but I'm genuinely curious as to
I mean I I'll just say it like when we
were planning this with v said he would
come on the show on Monday following the
caucus I'm wondering what changed with
the results what they expected what
happened on the road perhaps it's
weather I don't know but as to why
they're like we're not going to make it
do the show without him and I'm like
okay probably this 8% I mean it's a gut
punch to anyone that was supporting that
guy and had hope that's like y he worked
really really he did work really hard he
went to every County I think more than I
mean luk you you were on the road with
them two days ago like 16 hours 17 hours
17 hours on the road yep and you guys
drove all over the state what did you do
what did you do wrong Luke no they drove
three hours away to six different events
and then three hours back which turned
into more like eight hours back because
there was a blizzard mhm MH so we got
the Super Chat I think it's interesting
Richard Cantini Jr said I just left the
caucus Ron showed up the speaker for
Nikki was a Democrat Trump 2024 let's go
hilarious yeah Phil what's the solution
man solution to what uh bypassing the
New World Order creating a global order
that represents American values you're
asking you're asking the most
blackpilled person sitting
here uh that's that's I I'm I'm dubious
as if there is a solution um but I do
think I do think that it's not going to
be politicians I think that it's going
to going to be a situation where we have
to have people that are not looking to
the government to do things for them and
that's going to be that's something that
starts with parents and the way they
raise their kids and and it starts with
culture and it start you know it's not
as as much as I think it's important to
have the right people uh in positions of
power just because of the fact that if
you have the wrong people in positions
of power they're going to impose things
on your life that you're not interested
in uh you know things that even even the
fact that they want to impose things on
you is bad that they want to impose
things on anyone is bad so go ahead no
no no just wrap your idea and then I'm
it's just that I mean you know that's
just I I I lost where I was going so go
go ahead I'm GNA ask a a different
question finish a point I don't want to
if you believe voting is going to save
you you're not paying attention we need
something more than just voting we need
to take personal responsibility for our
lives which I think is more important
than anything else and that is you know
Mike cernovich had a great tweet a long
time ago he said make money you know
like raise your family protect your kids
and that's the first step something that
affected and he's right after that I
think culture building inspiring people
Genera what what V is doing going around
and spreading his message to all of
these young people is extremely
effective for the Next Generation so
that's absolutely fantastic I'm
wondering however if DeSantis Haley
ramaswami and even Trump if anyone
expected the race to be called literally
like 20 minutes in yeah with less than
1% reporting 200 votes come in they go
he won it's over I can't imagine anybody
anticip ated that that was shocking at I
know maybe that's why V team is like
look it's going to be 7:45 the results
haven't come in yet we'll come and talk
about it cross our fingers now it's like
you've lost already like well let's go
to the party I guess this is set what
were you say I have a question so when
they called it they called it at
1% were people less than 1% so so people
hadn't even voted yet could that have
been like they did they did well no it
was uh Jeremy Redford who said that he
in a district that hadn't voted yet so
could that be a form of election
interference to say everybody just go
home no point now it's called oh that's
actually a good point yeah if if the
that's actually a really and that's
where redr said it was rigged I mean
he's talking about that kind of thing
yeah I mean what's the point like if
you're waiting at the caucus and then
you know you're you hear that Trump
already won you're like well it's cold
on your phone says Trump won then
everybody goes home I mean that that
just seemed a little sketchy to me yeah
I wow wow yeah that's a great point I
don't like
that that's but I don't think that's why
uh the results are the results no no
that's that's not why I have feeling the
powers that be or these the people
whatever you want to call it I don't
know what it is this deep State thing
that they they they know Trump's going
to get the votes they they've accepted
that they think ramaswami will actually
disentangle the system so they don't
want to even give him name recognition
and so they're letting Trump get the
numbers and then they're going to try
and find some way
to make him stub his own toe and then we
got I guess Ron and Nikki to battle it
out I mean going back to what you were
talking about earlier with like a a
Global a globalist agenda but with
American values I I don't think that
that's that's possible just because the
globalist agenda is inherently like
socialist and the Socialist agenda goes
against our instinct to put ourselves
first or our families first it says you
have to share everything you know and
that's it's just not a natural in so I I
real quick I pulled up the polling from
Iowa from 538 the aggregate polling from
538 and Haley was actually expected to
defeat Ronda sandis by a couple points
so far at 40 % Ron is winning I don't
know if that means anything but uh we it
does seem to be trending exactly as the
polls predicted which is kind of crazy
considering what V was doing going
around and meeting people and that the
fact that he was winning firsttime
voters it's fascinating the polls are as
accurate as they are he spent I think 16
million I don't want to get the number
wrong but he spent his own money and I
think it was that but this is just an
example that mass of the power of mass
media Hitler Rose to power because of
radio and TV like the guy you can drive
and spend 15 hours a day every day but
if you're not using mass media yeah but
think about I mean think about it's
first of all it's Donald Trump who had
like 100% name recognition before he won
the presidency in 2016 yeah and then you
know you've got all of the things that
have happened since he won the first one
I mean it's not a surprise obviously
it's not a surprise that he won tonight
and it really if you think about it it
shouldn't come as a shock that he won by
such a large margin you know he's again
his name recognition is almost 100% %
and the majority of Republicans think
that there was at least something unfair
about the last election they they all
kind of well I assume most Republicans
kind of agree that all of the different
things all of the mail-in ballots all
those sending out ballots to people all
that stuff changed the dynamic so much
that it wasn't a a standard election and
had it been a standard election it's
likely that Donald Trump would have won
so I I don't think that this should come
as any kind of shock you know when Time
Magazine uh explained that there was a
shadow campaign to fortify the election
against trump it became clear to most
most all of them actually oh Tim's going
to pull it up good I remember when I saw
that the first time I was shocked and I
showed a friend and his reply was well
you know that's politics and I was like
I was flabbergasted that he said that I
was like that's really how you
understand this as that's just politics
they're saying that the government
itself was working against the incumbent
president and you're just like well
that's
what's interesting the head voters of
the country fair enough yeah the
headline the secret history of the
Shadow campaign history that saved this
is established I was astounded I
couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
that they had the audacity to print that
and then like I said when I told my you
know fairly blue pilled buddy I was like
do you see this and he's like yeah well
that's politics I'm like oh my God I'm
going to shoot myself you know the
reason I think that a global order that
uh embodies American constitutional
ideal as possible is because of the way
we've built the United States it's such
a vast territory but we were able to
unify 50 different concepts into one
kind of un gigant which would have been
thought totally impossible uh before the
Advent of electricity and or discovery
of electric an advent of radio I this
article is extremely important for
everyone who's never heard heard of to
read it outright says a conspiracy was
unfolding behind the scenes to C uh one
that both curtailed protests and
coordinated the resistance from C
CEOs they say quote within days after
the election we witnessed an
orchestrated effort to anoint the winner
while many key states were still being
counted that's from Trump they say he
was right a conspiracy was unfolding
behind the scenes handshake between
business and labor was one component of
a vast cross-partisan campaign to quote
protect the election an extraordinary
Shadow effort dedicated not to winning
the vote but to ensuring it would be
free and fair credible and uncorrupted
how this is the epitome of of corruption
and evil it is it is incredible how
distopian it is like it is it's almost
it's so audacious that you kind of feel
like no one would write this in a comic
book MH you know because no one would
believe it everyone would be like no
that's too they would they would never
do that then then write it well to to be
fair I think didn't Lex Luther win the
presidency legitimately probably I think
that I could be wrong like in a movie if
a villain did that they would be talking
about it in a boardroom not writing an
article and putting it online that that
that they put that online that they
admitted it that was their dystopian
Victory lab they they like it was like
you know you know the evildoers in every
single movie before they lose they tell
the they sell their their dastardly plan
to their victim and then then the
animals show up and and kill them what
happens but they they waited till after
their corruption unfolded and then told
us all their plans so I mean this is
what can expect this is what they do
it's literally them saying do something
about it why don't we uh it's just them
being like this is what we did and you
have not there's nothing you can do
about it we're going to go to our live
version of super chats and we're going
to ask audience questions Clint Clint
Russell up microphone if you guys could
if anybody wants to ask a question just
like lightly raise your hand we don't
want to have people queue up but slip a
five in Ian's pants and and I will I
will I will just say for here uh we'll
try to keep it family friendly but ask
away we didn't prescreen anything we're
just going to let people sort of ask
their questions don't get us
demonetized go ahead I'm more worried
about the children but also yes we like
money
too what's your name my name is Skyler I
just got verified on Twitter the the man
the oh nice oh congrat and your question
sir so this is a question for Luke um as
you can see I'm wearing my trans
vaccinated shirt I know you're antix um
will you stand up for all the ZM zerv
that are trans
Ved uh as long as you're not
uh shedding on me I I think we should be
fine and not aggressing against me in
any way uh will be cool you know we all
we all just have to follow the
non-aggression principle and everybody
can get along right yeah yeah yeah and
and if you if you shed your you know um
the
anyway I got stuck I want to say some
things I can't say on this platform but
uh yeah as long as you don't uh violate
my nap I won't violate your nap and we
should respect everyone for who they are
especially if they are free human beings
that do awesome things and don't spread
bad things to other people I'll keep it
at that also we have regular super chats
as well but I don't know if there's any
other anyone else um but thank you for
your question I just got a a message
somebody said Nancy Pelosi biographer
wrote that time article Molly ball why
will no one say this out loud it was her
Pelosi told the story to her I'd bet oh
yeah yeah it's it's it's Molly ball on
the time article that is who it is by
yep so that's who that's who it is yep
your name sir Kyle and your question uh
how do you how do like normal people how
are they supposed to like consume so
much media without becoming blackpilled
you got to find like ways in your
day-to-day life that keep you sane like
working out sauna um communication with
friends and things it's like about real
stuff like where your food and like that
that's one way to do it I think I mean
if we're talking about you're consuming
legitimate media that is reporting
honestly black pilling is an IND
individual state of mind which I would
agree with Ian you've got to improve
yourself send to yourself figure it out
because I think if you're actually
consuming all the media we got tons of
reasons to be optimistic I know Phil
said he's the most black person
blackpilled most the most blackpilled
person here that too brother yeah but uh
I mean we're looking at all these
tremendous victories of the last year
and now Nikki Haley's you know
humiliating defeat to Ronda santis I
mean like we got reasons to be
optimistic Ron's not going to win either
but with uh uh I mean budlight boycott
Target etc etc it's just looking better
and better I mean look the fact that V
even did as well as he did and the hard
work he's putting in there is a a bright
future for uh for us I think we win this
it's going to be hard but I think we win
yeah lift heavy thing makes sad voice
stop yeah I I'd go further uh just to to
what what they were saying is uh make
sure you of purpose make sure you you
you love something greater than yourself
and uh it's it's easy to not get
blackpilled celebrate the small
victories and understand that a
corruption is being exposed which is a
good thing that you're finally being
made aware of I'm going to read a Super
Chat real quick and then we'll jump to
this question Paul tascal says when VI
called out eminent domain carbon
pipeline they basically deleted him I
was an uh how do I scroll on this thing
it's I don't know if it's letting me
scroll here on YouTube let me zoom out
so I can get the full thing I was an ed
lawyer for three years it's deeply
corrupt everyone is paid off layered at
every level local County state and
federal and courts has a big issue in
Iowa that most people nationally don't
know about trying to seize land for I
believe it's to build this pipeline is
that it I'm not sure what pipeline but I
I agree I me the domain is is really
really bad in my opinion and V came out
called it out said no you can't do this
and then he's just then he doesn't
appear on the polls of the charts
anymore what's your name sir my name's
David hey David hey I live in Arkansas
now I came up here hopefully to meet Vic
and a little bigger celebration than we
had but that's all good I was living in
De Mo um in 188 in 1988 1888 and I
happened to hear Rush limau uh the third
day he was on the air I picking up a VP
for company down at the airport and and
I was a nobody like I'm not am now still
and uh and he spoke to me um he passed
away uh basically when Biden took office
and you came into my life and I just
want to thank you um for being kind of a
boomer thing perhaps but you are the new
voice for me that kind of Rush was and I
just kind of interested in um if he had
any influence on you your thoughts on
him uh I know it's a little generational
but yeah I I never listens to listened
to rush once the only exposure I've ever
had to rush limbo was when he came out
on Family Guy that about it but uh I I
my understanding is he's basically the
progenitor of talk radio and uh so mad
massive respect yeah I don't know about
any anyone else here I don't oh yeah
when I was a kid my parents used to
blare
that that theme song is burned into my
head for all of eternity y are doing a
pretty good job of channeling his energy
and I want to thank you for that thanks
for coming I appreciate it during
impeachment in the uh late 90s I
remember listening to Rush a lot talking
about the impeachment stuff for W my
child was like I thought he was the bad
guy cuz I was like oh he's the hateful
conservative the Republican guy and my
dad voted for Clinton so I didn't know
any better but I appreciate what he did
Big Time
now right on what's your name uh my
name's Roy question yeah the question is
uh so um it's pretty much been
established that Nikki Haley is the
establishment candidate um what do you
suppose is going to happen with her
voters because I know uh personally uh a
few people that are Haley fans and they
call Trump a felon uh and I don't know
if they're going to really vote at all
this uh election cycle of Haley isn't
the nominee so what do you how Who who
how do you have you asked them like why
they're fans of Haley because they hate
Trump yeah but then they could be a fan
of Ronda antis he doesn't even come up
in their in their conversations Nikki
Haley yeah the mainstream media pushed
her so hard the last four months that's
right to Clinton voters all the Hillary
Clinton voters my parents are talking
about her and they're like Democrats
crazy I don't think they understood her
connection with Boeing in the military
industrial complex and oh yeah but I
mean Warhawk Democrats love that stats
that are it's look I I I kind of feel
like if a Nikki Haley vo voter is not
going to vote then we dodge a bullet
let's let let's encourage all the Nicki
Haley voters not to vote if it's Donald
Trump we don't you know take their
because because what they're gonna vote
for Biden uh actually this is what um
was it I think Bruce Woods was pointing
out elad eliahu who does reporting for
cnr.com produced several videos coming
out of the Hal campaign uh events where
he just these are not gotcha questions
he's not a partisan guy he's got his
political opinions for sure that he
calls himself the Bolton bro but he goes
and he asks you know why do you support
Nikki Haley if Nikki Haley is not the
Nomine it's looking like Trump will be
who will you vote for they say Joe
Biden so they'll probably vote for Biden
but I think it doesn't matter if you
look at the polls we're looking right
now at the iow polls and they're they're
they're fairly accurate I mean they're
they're hitting the nail in the head
that's surprising I thought V actually
was going to beat the polls because he
was playing this ground game with
younger voters uh so far it's he's
tracking trending with the polls so
we'll see how that plays out but I think
if we're looking at the polls and they
are as accurate as they've been younger
voters are going for Trump Joe Biden
cannot win when they put Trump up
against Nikki Haley Ron and Ronda santis
they they they have some of the latest
polls showing what's the percentage
going to be Trump V Biden S V Biden
Haley V Biden they all win Biden loses
to every single person so I don't I
think VI is right about their
play Nikki Haley is their candidate not
Joe Biden we're all talking about oh you
know Joe Biden's gonna get sick in March
maybe and then maybe they do tap Nome or
something but the question then becomes
how do you get rid of kamla Harris if
Biden drops out kamala's next in line
right it's simple EV Vic's right Nikki
Haley is how you get past KLA Harris
have your establishment candidate run as
a republican against Trump and the real
election is the
primary yeah she's the uni party yeah
thanks ma' so I'm glad to see Trump
winning and I hope that remains the case
but you know what I think too
everybody's gearing up for the shadow
campaign of
2024 yo Shadow campaign may be happening
right now yep it the shadow campaign
we're going to get an article in 2025
when we're all shocked Nikki Haley's the
president and it's going to be like the
shadow campaign to win 2024 through the
GOP Primary yep yep name in your
question sir um my name is Jay it's kind
of spelled like the letter but a little
different um so looking at Trump you
have a 77y old who is political poison
for some people with the entire deep
State weaponized against him and the CIA
has heart attack guns I mean not related
but thanks Luke that's true that's old
Tech so if he has taken down um what
what names are you looking at as uh
people that are up and coming who who
who would you attach yourself to oh
Chris
Christie I would his plan to invade
Candyland is one of most really foreign
policy interventions I've ever heard I
don't know Ryan Binkley looks pretty
promising number five right there well
hold on do we know anything about
binkley's platform I know he got 266
votes to Christy's 16 like what if he's
just like a really nice guy who loves
his like who loves his State and was
being you know he wasn't even running
he's just a really nice guy and everyone
know like is he on the Belt no but
everybody knows him and he's a good dude
oh I think V's the obvious uh uh pitch
the dude is such a hardworking guy he's
brilliant and he's he's got some some of
the most Libertarian uh uh pitches that
we've seen in any Republican candidate
so I I don't see anybody else right now
I mean I don't think Matt Gates is going
in that direction Matt Gates is pretty
awesome but who else is there JD Vance
is pretty cool too yeah Vance is doing
well he's he's he's a good dude I like V
not only for his libertarian but he's
very constitutional if you've seen him
speak he talks about the founding
documents the founding fathers he knows
his history which which I appreciate he
knows the real history because
everything kind of got switched around
in the 60s if you don't know that but he
knows the real stuff and that that
speaks to Integrity I do like um a lot
of people stting starting to bring up
that Dei is the Natural Evolution I like
to call it Dee it's way better because
Dei means god and die means death so
we'll go with that one but it's the
Natural Evolution of the Civil Rights uh
laws and it sort of is it's the extreme
version of of them but I always tell
people just because someone corrupted a
thing doesn't mean a thing was always
bad you know what I mean yeah like look
you know maybe cake is good but if
you're eating cake every single day it's
bad yeah we we passed laws saying we
don't want people to discriminate or
whatever and there are certain
limitations to it like back when they
passed this bill nobody thought they'd
get rid of women's sports I don't know
that they had women's sports at the time
but nobody thought they would be like
you know males can use female bathrooms
that's not the intent but then you get
this corruption through nefarious forces
which start breaking things down which
proves the law is beating the only thing
matters is what a society is willing to
accept and we mention a lot there's
these laws on the books and there are
blue laws some some of them are called
that were made back in the day that no
one follows anymore like the favorite
gag one which I think is no longer in
play was women can't go skydiving on
Sunday in Florida I think that's I read
about that like it's been overturned or
whatever but there were weird laws like
that no cop's going to arrest a woman
for skydiving in Florida on Sunday they
should but when you look at uh you know
civil rights law and where it's at right
now we're surprised to see how it's
being implemented and I think a lot of
this has to do with uh originalist
versus textualism people who are like if
it says regulated and today regulated
this the stupidest argument in the world
I mean these people are just despicable
the Second Amendment says a
well-regulated militia well we know what
the founding fathers meant when they
wrote it but because today regulated
means government control that's what it
means that's the stupidest idea I've
ever heard why on Earth why why after
winning a war
Where The Red Coats confiscated ammo and
guns from the people of Massachusetts
why on Earth would the founding fathers
be like yeah you know what we should
have the government regulate our guns
that's what we're going to do that is
just so dumb so dumb the percentage of
votes in went down by 1% did Nikki
Haley's number go down it did a lot good
yeah a lot they just pulled a bunch of
votes back that is sketchy wait remember
when this happened on CNN everyone said
it was rigged there was like the the
vote time for Trump changed and I'm like
people are saying how did that happen
I'm like maybe the uh AP doing the
official reportings that we made a
mistake and and pulled it back or
clicked cancel I don't know but it was
at 39% Haley was at 8,000 now she's at
7,000 so I have no idea what that means
but you know how fun Nicki haly's votes
went down are at 9300 you're at 9,300
yeah 40 40 bound delegates where you at
four I'm on the New York Times 40 I'm on
CNN CNN has Nick Hal with 40 delegates
no no there are 40 bound right I was
like at 9,300 votes huh interesting I
wonder the New York Times is just uh is
breaking all right let's get another
question in there NE your question five
b my name is Lucas Carter I have kind of
a two-part question uh so do you
especially Luke have any uh thoughts on
the similarity between Vex campaign and
Ron Paul say 20182 and do you think uh
as he gets older and is kind of getting
out of the picture more I grew up off of
his ideals uh do you see him possibly
being a Jin Z replacement
at the beginning of this election I
always told everyone that what matters
here is not who gets the votes it's the
ideas that get pushed it's the Overton
window that gets pushed um I think
vivi's doing a great job at that there's
a lot of ROM Paul people that are within
his campaign there's a lot of ROM paaul
people that I met on the campaign Trail
so the there is a crossover here as of
course A lot of the same ideas not all
of them but but some of these great
ideas of of you know Freedom you know
Liberty personal responsibility are
being shared here and those ideas
especially in the minds of young people
are critically important so I do see a
lot of crossover I do see a lot of
actual people that were raw and PAW
people here on the ground be a part of
the the Vivic campaign as well so so
there is some crossover uh foreign
policy wise there there's there's a lot
of difference especially when it comes
to Mexico and and and China uh but but
over but overall um there is kind of a
larger kind of um energy that does
resonate very similarly
and and what censorship as far as in
terms of the the med yeah yeah and then
also what what what it what kind of
happened to him earlier happened to Ron
Paul uh many many years ago as of course
the corporate media was against him and
uh rigging the process against them in
many unfair ways now to be fair
CNN.com has this little widget in the
left that only has Trump to sis and
Haley but when you click it they don't
hide v ramaswami he's included in their
list with Asa Hutchinson behind him so I
got to give CNN credit the people who
are running they put him in there what
was that where's where's Chris Christie
not running Ryan the what those other
guys his plan to invade Candyland did
you write that like last night you were
waiting to say I was waiting to say it
yeah I was like what am I going to be
able to get that Zinger out there when
he funded the coup against the gum drop
princess I just thought that
was absolutely insane they're like
liberated the the fudge swamp remember
that clip where it was who was like who
was it who asked him she's like uh
you're very overweight why did you be
president and he's like Barbara Walters
yeah it Barbara
Walters and she was like some say you
shouldn't be president cuz your like oh
that's ridiculous she's like why are you
so heavy and he's like if I knew I would
fix it orever why that's such a sad
answer I mean I've tried everything
there's a clip of Ron Paul telling a guy
in the audience that he's fat and he
needs to lose weight I remember that
really yeah was a doctor said maybe the
government should put you on a diet I
saw what he said yes yeah cuz the guy
was like talking about how government
should take care
of he was so mad andul like govern
should be a diet great Chris chrisy
actually got gastric bypass and just
blasted right through it I'm I'm
impressed honestly it's true you're name
in your question s yeah I'm James I've
came down from uh Minnesota had some
time to waste in the hotel and I turned
on MSNBC just to see what they were
talking about and I think it was mattow
said the one feature of the Iowa caucus
is is anyone can go and and vote or
caucus for in the Republican primaries
even if they don't typically identify as
a republican yep so wow that that's that
was a component of their plan there was
also wasn't there some Scandal where
like desantis's team said people from
out of state should show up or something
like that I remember something like what
was that about it was like it was like
Ron's wife or something right yeah it
was misinformation for sure like real
misinformation not not not the other
stuff yeah don't do that I'm pretty sure
that's illegal mhm yeah what up is that
an Aaron no it's not Aaron Rog on the
Jets now right Rand Cobb he's on the
Jets too now but oh right well you know
so my name is uh Jason heightman Tim
you're the first person in my entire
life to get my name right on the first
try I super
chatted yeah those substitute teachers
really made my prepubescent life hell
maybe they're doing on purpose though no
they say like jazzing and then everyone
laughs at me and stuff J A a z a n huh M
but um so my question well I was really
complaining about my state politics here
I'm from Wisconsin obviously and um no
one's really talking about what's going
on in our state right now I feel like
we're losing our state last election I
do too last election um not a lot of
turnout on the conservative side we
elected uh Supreme Court Justice for our
state a liberal and she ran on the fact
that our maps are gerrymandered and now
they just decide that maps are UNC
unconstitutional they're going to redraw
the maps for this next election and all
of our congressional seats are going to
be up for re-election why all of them
that's what I heard um it could you know
take that grain of salt but that's
iander EST
State what's that they gerrymandered a
state they say that our our maps are
gerrymandered towards the conservatives
after the last census that we
gerrymandered them so now instead we
always do it every census as we redraw
the maps right now they're saying
they're gerrymandered unconstitutional
now there's a liberal majority in
Supreme Court they're overturning it and
they need to draw new maps by the next
election this could be why the RNC is
going to be in Milwaukee so that'll be
interesting I think there's going to be
a push for Wisconsin it's a very
important state to not let Democrats
take over but yo if they pull that
they're taking over it's a very purple
State I mean where where I live it's
really half I live by uh W ashkash it's
like the North End of the city is very
liberal because the college and then is
very conservative it's everywhere you go
you don't know who's on your side that's
how it usually is the people who do the
actual work that makes this country
happen vote on the right and then people
who are in the institutionalized
learning facilities vote left that's the
kind of thing that the RNC should be
fighting they should have lawyers they
should or they should be looking to
prevent that kind of stuff this is one
of the reason why Ron Ron McDaniels is
such a failure and such a joke uh I
don't know I don't know what they you
know why they're not trying to play ball
like trying trying to you know defend
the the the the system as it is they
this is part of the reason why Donald
Trump lost is because the RNC allowed
the the Democrats in Pennsylvania and
stuff to change to you know
unconstitutionally according to
Pennsylvania's Constitution change the
the way that electors are sent and stuff
the it's it's an absolute failure on R's
part and I don't know why Trump endorsed
her so so frustrating what article makes
mandering unconstitutional is that in
they they just they said from the
article I read they just said that the
maps are Jerry mannered towards the
conservative side and that I don't know
I don't remember Dei their Maps got it
so yeah that I'm just I'm just scared
that because we right now our our
governor is um Tony iers like my dad
likes to say I don't like iers and then
our Congress is mostly conservative so
it's just like iers does something we
say the the Congress says no Congress
says something I says no there's nothing
going on in our state right now it's a
constant just stalemate nothing's
happening but they start to sway their
way we're going to start it's going to
affect us because we're purple I mean we
we have good strong gun laws but they're
not getting stronger and they could
definitely go go in in every aspect we
we're gonna we're going to win those
fights at the Supreme Court for a long
time I mean the current make of the
Supreme Court is is pretty good for a
while yeah and then another thing I'm
worried our state's kind of being
invaded by your old State Tim we call
them fibs I'm sure you know what that
term means what is it effing Illinois
bastards oh okay I don't I don't know
that because I was from Illinois we
didn't call ourselves that yeah yeah
yeah yeah well especially in mass and
Milwaukee a lot of people from Illinois
are moving to Wisconsin because like
apparently our welfare benefits are
better well also because Illinois is
just like a failed state so yeah but
it's like it's they're they're bringing
their policies with them it scared build
a wall uh so we're we're
planning uh highly likely we'll do
another show like this at the RNC for
that full week so we'll probably have
like a series of shows at some you know
rented location and then maybe like a
bigger show with an audience for
Thursday with the final day of the RNC
and we're definitely not going to the
DNC because it's in Chicago and I feel
like someone's going to get shot yep I I
don't even I'm I'm kind of like I'm not
trying to be cute man I I think there's
a high likelihood of like there's going
to be riots there's going to be serious
injury cops are look at the N no NATO
protests Luke and I were there the cops
arrested a group of leftist activists
and detained them for like 10 days in
what's called a black site that it's
basically a police controlled facility
no one knows about where these people
were detained without word no one knew
where they went and disappeared they
were disappeared in Chicago we I
literally had a cop like put a gun to my
head uh when we were pulled over they
tried planting drugs on us I'm not not
not a joke that's literally what
happened yeah it's a crazy story and
this really happened Chicago is is the
whole place is so dirty the state itself
is so dirty and the idea that there's
going to be a DNC you know the the the
we went to the DNC at uh I think it was
what 2016 MH the RNC and the DNC were so
fun back back the Cycles you know like
you know Jimmy dor spit on Alex Jones
how fun was that we were there in that
room and it holy crap and that was at
the RNC but nobody protested the RNC
nobody cared the DNC there were thous
thousand of protesters trying to storm
the barricades and break their way in yo
DNC in Chicago is going to be Bonkers
corrupt cops corrupt government all
Democrat controlled gun violence I'm not
going anywhere near that place D your
question sir uh my name is Cameron
before I ask my question I'd just like
to say as a fine Irishman I don't see
how people could accuse you of sealing
spoons Sheamus thank you I you know I
appreciate that because I wouldn't do
that and you know
me is the question never do that than
brother never steal a spoon as as
Irishman would never steal spoons God
bless you thank you I sense a conspiracy
here yeah it was more of an observation
that he did it on top of being thieves
they're all
liar can you believe this littleit bias
on this panel why do we put up with this
I I I don't know first the Patty wagons
now this it's sickening that is funny
they still call them that Patty wagons I
don't think it's funny at all I think
that's funny stop drinking he does think
it's funny he's laughing
no no I'm serious
uh so with having friends that are on
the left and that are pretty much in the
leftist cult how do you start them out
and trying to move them over at all when
you have articles like the secret
history of the how they fortified the
election and people that like Phil said
think that that's a good thing it's
super easy what you do is uh get a bunch
of them call a bunch of your Lefty
friends you like 10 or whatever I don't
know and tell them you got this great
idea for you know this this cool event
they should come to then you tell all
your friends and you trick them all into
going to the community center where you
lock the doors and make them stay there
overnight so they become friends yeah
that's all you do uh or you can talk to
them I mean it's it's like this the
simple answer is kind of
boring uh ask them questions the
Socratic method if you argue with them
and tell them that they're wrong or
insult them they'll get angrier so if
you have friends who are on the left you
can be like you know whenever they say
something just pull up on your phone a
source from a like this is why I always
like using CNN and NPR and their sources
I like using corporate press sources to
debunk what they're saying and I I often
tell people too they're like the media
never reported this thing I'll be like
dude I pulled it up on the New York
Times they reported on it it's just the
the the Democrat establishment forces
will ignore stories from the corporate
press so if uh if if someone claims Joe
Biden never did insert thing I'm going
to make sure the report comes from CNN
because then they can't deny it so it's
things like that other than that it's
tough the reality is to to change
someone's mind mind and help them
understand you need to surround them
with people who will influence them you
can if you reorient people towards kind
of what Occupy Wall Street was about
which is international banking like that
really is the biggest threat to our way
of life is corporate um I
totalitarianism technocracy so there is
a there is something that all all
Americans can focus on at least most
Americans can focus on that we can agree
with that like having corporations run
our lives is not ideal
yeah and you have to be gentle with how
you do it because these people since at
least 2012 2013 with the ndaa they
haven't been told they were wrong in a
very long time they've had their
confirmation bias inflated for 12
straight years she's right you have to
let them come to it so like present them
with the idea and then allow them don't
try to make them change their mind don't
try to change anyone's mind you'll never
ever do it present them with stuff that
conflicts with their preconceived notion
and just let it go just let them and
like you know don't constantly do it but
every once in a while be like oh you see
this or something like that and let them
change at their own pace if they feel
like you're trying to convince them of
anything the walls go up the heels get
dug in the dirt just let them change
there's a dude that I'm very very close
with that is very anti-trump and very
very blue pilled after Joe Biden was
elected and after he saw the results his
tone about politics is 100% different
than it was right before uh right before
Joe Biden was elected and it is much
easier to talk to him but you can't I
you never try and shove anything down
anyone's throat never try and make
anyone see things a different way always
just give them the option real quick
just uh with the data coming out of the
New York Times a lot more of the voters
come in there's still is a slim
possibility based on their estimates
that Nikki Haley beats Ronda santis
they're projecting Haley between 17 and
21% to desantis's 19 to 23 I don't think
it's likely and uh uh the is still
sitting around uh eight they expect him
to hit around seven to n interestingly
Nikki Haley did end up losing Johnson
County which was uh uh supposedly this
very you know liberal area Trump trump
won nick uh Nikki Haley currently has
Story County and I would also say it's
kind of sad uh we actually saw V doing
rather well but I'm not sure actually
has any counties in third place I see
him with one bound delegate which is
good but I think okay here we go he's in
third place in appan County so far and
the neighboring Wayne County so he does
have some where he's in third place you
scrolled over P County earlier where's
that at uh it's below De Moine somewhere
below there Congressman Massi had
tweeted that or shouted out that uh um
DeSantis won it but you when you pulled
it up it was um you sure it's below yeah
I'm pretty sure
oh okay it is one right okay yeah yeah
Trump yeah it was for Trump uh Thomas
Massie said that it was for Dan santis
um yeah I guess he got early results and
it it wasn't though Massie Massie what a
silly thing to tweet I know yeah TI T we
still love you it's okay your question
man um my name is Julie I'm visiting
here from Nebraska and um I just needed
to represent the ladies I don't know if
you guys noticed that there's about a
six or 7 to one ratio out here of guys I
have not noticed the
I bring that up all the
time no I I I I I point that out in the
show several times like you go to any
like events sporting event or whatever
it's always like eight 8
to2 four to one yeah I'm in a metal band
um I'm actually politically um active in
my in Nebraska and so I and and then
I've come up here to Iowa to um work
with the team Trump events and um I've
also been able to go to RFK Junior event
in Nebraska and a the um vies um event
here last week on or on Wednesday and I
just wanted to point out there's a lot
of energy at a lot of these events but
um they're not people from Iowa the Iowa
people I think are you know you can't
judge by what you see in the crowds um I
think that they get
oversaturated um I've done the caucus
cards and uh there was a couple events
where most of the crowd was from
Nebraska South Dakota and these other
states so I think uh there is energy for
Vi um it's just not all centered in in
Iowa so I think he he has U the
potential to to do better um in the
future but uh I love going to these
events but they're very very very
deceiving when you a lot of the people
drive you know really long ways to come
to these yeah the actual amount of
people from Iowa that I talked to is
probably 5 10% of the of the people that
I would talk to at an at an event well
let's do this uh show of hands how many
people in the room right now are from
Iowa so it was like half yeah maybe okay
like currently living in Iowa
Y is that is that less I about same
about half about half and that makes
sense a lot of people drove drove here
from neighboring states or from a few
hours out uh I'd imagine with internet
popularity you you know I talked about
this with like AOC and we're talking
with like Civil War stuff back in the
day everything was much more Regional
AOC is able uh it's not just her the
squad if you look at where their revenue
comes from their donations
overwhelmingly from outside their own
District they are internet candidates
that represent an amorphous online
nebulous Community with no Geographic uh
you know Center Point and even for this
show it's obvious that about half the
people are from Iowa were in Iowa so
it's easy for them to come somebody who
lives in New York is not going to come
to this event it's too difficult but
people from Minnesota or from Illinois
or you know slightly neighboring areas
might take the drive to come visit
because it's an opportunity same thing
is going to happen to vake or any other
internet-based candidate I just had one
more thing to the gentleman from from
Wisconsin that was talking about the um
the state turning or being purple and um
the best way to change that is to get
involved on the local level um in
Nebraska we were run by pretty big Rhino
Pete Ricketts I don't know he was our
governor and 75% of the funding for our
party um the Grassroots took over um in
2022 and are changing the direction of
the party and bringing in more
Grassroots and there's definitely more
energy but the only way you're going to
make change on that is at the local
level because that's where these laws
are voting laws and um all those
procedures come from your state
legislature yep so don't look past um
what's going on in your local area and
focus too much on what's Happening um
nationally yeah Julie is absolutely
right it's it's about getting on your
school board your Sheriff's Department
your select board starting there working
your way into uh State Senate state
representative uh and that that's where
you're going to make the changes when
the Communists infiltrated America they
started at a very small level and they
work their way up into the prominent
positions in every institution and and
you know if they're good at anything um
it's it's it's organizing and uh that's
what they did and uh we can learn
something from the
Communists Tim I know you have a heart
out in 10 minutes one more or two more
uh I think maybe two more if we try and
go quick I mean I don't know we have 10
minutes but we do have a hard out so
name and question sir uh Alec I actually
have two questions so oh too many no
next
person I want to step back to the
beginning of the show um you guys were
talking about the tunnels in New York
City uh Sheamus is it like the the
stealing of the spoons just happened
stance that you dug
those
another sick false accusation I will not
hear it I will not you took those spoons
all right so my real question is uh we
talk about dismantling the corporate
governments around uh the FBI the ATF
the CIA and everything else I I love the
idea about that but I've been like
reading to books on tape and so on and
there's a lot of things talking about
like uh like the uh dictators down in
South America um was it uh Condor
project Condor whever it was a lot of
the times you'd have these systems that
are being torn down and often they're
being replaced in the back and through
other governments basically that tear
them down what what chances do you think
if we tear down the CIA the ATF and all
those other ones would they just be
replaced with even more tyrannical worse
people I don't know about worse but
possibly maybe the same but it's hard to
know for sure it just depends on who uh
uh depends on the degree to which we win
culturally if uh you know I think that
that what Ron Paul say abortion
shouldn't be illegal it should be
Unthinkable yeah both and so that that's
an idea that that expands well beyond
just the concept of abortion so many
things should be Unthinkable to our
culture that are becoming permissible
even though people generally don't like
them and so when it comes to we get we
elect we elect the Donald Trump let's
say in 2028 V is the guy and he ends up
winning and he's massively popular for
whatever reason and then we get you know
with Donald Trump you get the firing of
the bureaucrats the relocation although
Trump has said what he wants to bolster
the FBI headquarters something so who
knows but let's say if a does crushing
everything maybe at this point
culturally we don't tolerate the
existence of these institutions and then
nothing replaces them it just depends I
think the interesting thing to think
about is why is it that in Russia you
can offer a bribe to a cop with no
question and no fear and then the United
States if no one would dare do it the
police officer has Scruples it's not
just that he fears doing doing something
wrong like that some cops will take
bribes for sure the average cop is like
yo I'll go to jail I'm scared like in
Russia the cop expects you to give him a
bribe there's a culture that's different
from the United States to Russia as it
pertains to what law law enforcement is
willing or capable to do capable of
doing and now in the United States law
enforcement Scruples have been eroded
now you've got cops in Texas who are
willing to actually engage in human
smuggling themselves and they don't care
why they fear nothing so as this
continues to erode if we don't change
this mentality you will get more and
more law enforcement at behaving like
they do in the collapsed former Soviet
States or the this so This former Soviet
States I'll just call them that and
what's I mean look when you're at the
point where cops are like I will take
money to engage in human smuggling and
facilitate crimes against this country
that's worse than accepting bribes so of
course the FBI is going to have massive
corruption it the CIA of course the Deep
State the the intelligence agencies what
solves that is when that cop is
terrified he will go to prison for the
rest of his life and that's a guarantee
you know you have this video from Taylor
Hansen tenant media shout out and the
cop's yelling at him the cop is worried
he'll get caught he just don't think he
doesn't think anyone will do anything
about it because the criminals are
running the clown show right now I mean
Biden's in office it's not going to
happen to him but if people find out oh
then he's going to get his neighbors are
going to yell at him so he doesn't like
being filmed we need to make sure one we
elect Donald Trump and if if something
bad happens you know God forbid someone
like V ramaswami if not V and then we
make sure each and every one of these
Law Enforcement Officers no Scruples are
back baby we will find you you will be
criminally charged and you will suffer
the consequences for breaking the law
then I don't care if we have an FBI or a
CIA I mean if the FBI was doing what the
FBI is on paper supposed to be doing
investigating federal crimes like let's
talk about what the FBI should do human
traffickers arrested child traffickers
arrested what do they really doing pull
rope in a garage investigation Donald
Trump orange man bad arrest his his
supporters who are bumbling around like
you know on on January 6 in
DC a a functioning legitimate Federal
investigative Bureau is fine so what we
need to do is it's simple whenn
culturally convince
everybody law enforcement exists you
will be held accountable for your
actions there is no escaping
it thank you much going on okay one
quick one I guess cuz
hard okay I'll come back to the caucus
here um so I'm Joe and two weeks ago a
canvas her for Dan santis came to my
door she's from Virginia and I she's
like what are you who are you gonna vote
for stuff like that and I said uh have
you checked out VC and she's like who H
she had no clue I pulled open Clips she
flipped she had a she had a danta shirt
on and she we sat down on our steps and
we watch Clips she's like I really like
this the old Switcheroo and so what's
interesting so this is a little per Pro
RC a little bit is that there needs to
be someone that is connecting with
people on this level that isn't Trump
he's great we'll vote for him but he's
coming in behind yeah and scooping up
people that don't have this Trump
mentality of no way never never never
but he V VC is actually selling the
American dream better than Trump in the
sense of his words showing it with his
family his kids are there it's a super
sweet dream and it's not Trump like oh
they hate me no it's great you know I'll
still vote for him but I'm saying that
he he's saying the the M the American
dream make America make America great
again but a lot of these younger kids
don't know what that means make America
great 10 years ago cuz that's when I was
born or whatever you know what I'm
saying so v v is actually painting that
picture really well and if be wasn't
part of it then it's just Trump and then
he and then say he gets in or whatever
it ends with him but we need somebody
painting that picture so then they he
Scoops in all these other people that
will actually go to Trump I got I got to
say one thing that was pointed out I
can't remember who pointed this out to
us and they said VI can never win
because even people who know him can't
pronounce his name right and the point
there is not that his name is odd or
whatever it's that that the amount of
like the fact that I mean you called him
VC even though he's repeatedly said it's
aake like cake and he has to correct
people all the time it means that he's
not pushing information enough to
individuals to know enough about him
Donald Trump is Unforgettable his name
is known by everybody when Hillary
Clinton made love Trump's hate signs I
thought she was when I first saw it I
was like she's telling me to love Trump
like Trump is hateful and I should love
his actions I don't understand oh they
meant love is better than hate I didn't
understand that because his name is just
it's always going to be the proper noun
Paramount the is doing a lot of great
things and he's spreading a really great
message but I think it is fair to say
that one example of how he's not
generating enough is that people don't
even know how to say his name it's
unfortunate it's it's it's it's I don't
I don't I don't know how you solve for
that but uh I agree with you I'm hoping
he can be the plan B back bench but uh
we do have a couple super chats that
have pointed out
after this election V is gone and the
idea is kind of like what keeps VI
relevant after this election if he's not
chosen for a position in the Trump
Administration and is not frequenting
the Press if he goes the podcast route
no that's great you know he'll be a
podcaster there's there's not a path
from there back to the presidency so I'm
not sure what his plan is but I do think
he's a smart enough guy to figure
something out the answer is going to
have to be if we do want v as you know
the upand cominging Young stars to look
forward to in the future Trump is going
to have to embrace can offer him some
kind of position or even if it's not
like a direct cabinet position it could
be some kind of like business consulting
position where V is kept in the light so
that you know going to the next cycle
he's there and in front of every you
know he's a musician I'd love to play uh
he's on Keys get him on Keys yeah for
something some hot hit song man because
I could see that guy just jamming dude
but uh uh I don't know if anyone else
wanted to wrap this one up before we do
our sign off anything else to say well
in that case thank you all so much for
hanging out for this uh live in Iowa
caucus show we're looking at all of the
other uh uh primary events we're trying
to figure it out because I'm not going
to say too much March our plan was for
this big show it may be changing and I
just want to say this Pittsburgh is it's
an impossible City I guess the leftist
influence is too extreme and the general
thing that we're hearing is the venues
let be very careful how I say this
without naming any individual group but
it would seem they're very terrified of
the very active far-left contingent and
the the threat of violence is legitimate
so I'm not sure that Pittsburgh will
allow us to do the show because if the
venues don't let us in they don't let us
in Cleveland Ohio is another option
perhaps akan Ohio yeah maybe Blossom
Music Center that place is hot we'll see
I got arrested in Pittsburgh it's not a
fun place to be in well then we'll you
know we'll see but uh at any rate thank
you all so much for for hanging out
watching the show smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net
follow them on
XB records uh on on x five times August
of course man that guy's got so much
Amazing Music he's so good yeah he's
amazing you should definitely check him
out and uh become a member because when
you do become a member you're basically
allowing us to budget for events like
this and we definitely have a bunch
planned we're planning the RNC not the
DNC but maybe we could do a DNC kind of
event back in Milwaukee again or
whatever I don't know we'll figure it
out uh so yeah become a member at
timcast.net
UPS video reports master classes and you
could even call in to uh thepolitical
show.com only $8 a month it means a lot
to us when you sign up the website is
luk unfiltered.com see you there right
after this my name is Sheamus cogin I
onun a channel called Freedom Tunes we
do animated cartoons if you all want to
go over there and check that out I'd
appreciate it there's also a chance I
might be appearing alongside Luke on his
show in the next week or there might be
some internal battles but but but you
got to plug your website the worst
political show.com no no no the it's
called.com if you URL do you have no it
is my I I bought the worst political
show.com and it redirects to Sheamus
yes that's that's good branding I
appreciate
it.com I look thank you for the
promotion say say it say go to Freedom
tunes.com a member pleas Freedom
tunes.com become a member thank you
political show.com it's easier to
remember oh it really does it redirect
direct Sheamus look yeah is real you're
welcome Sheamus you're a good friend
thank you thank
you I'm uh Ian Crossland you guys follow
me on the internet and tomorrow I'll be
interviewing my father I'm very excited
we're just gonna we're going to shoot
the see what happens I want to find
out he was he was in the Navy during
Vietnam he's got an interesting
perspective on all this stuff so it be
really fun that'll be in the afternoon
about 1 pm Eastern Standard Time on
YouTube check it out I am uh Phil that
remains on X I'm Phil that remains
official on Instagram the band is All
That Remains you can follow us on
Spotify Apple music Amazon music Pandora
you know the
internet and I'm Josie I'm the redheaded
libertarian over on X and I host a show
called spaces with Josie which you can
watch on X or on membersonly at
timcast.net now we are going to get in
our cars and drive on icy roads to get
to a jet so we can make it back to the
studio so I can record once again at
like 88 or 9:00 a.m. it's going to be a
lot of fun thanks for hanging out we'll
see you'all
tomorrow